state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is an executive session
and this i'll read it again this
afternoon when we go into hearing which
will be a little bit different
of scheduled bills referred to the
education committee executive sessions
on pending legislation may also be held
please note that there is no physical
location for members the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i'm confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate
in this meeting by zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600
or email hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us today
jennifer four our committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required by
the right to know law
madam clerk
can you hear us representative shaw
trying to unuse okay
there you go good
morning oh
it's a great one electronically i'll
tell you right now
um
mute unless you're speaking
okay
is it me that's echoing
yeah i think that is you um rep shot
hold on
just give me one second
okay
maybe
um
[Music]
sorry i i don't know whether to gin
maybe you can help
all right here wait a minute
take this out in the other room
all right how about now
perfect
representative cordelli
where'd he go in my home alone
representative baum
[Music]
uh representative bowman i believe was
testifying in another committee at nine
o'clock he's probably so doing okay
representative allard
[Music]
representative lakes
representative moffat
i am alone at my loudoun villa
representative hobson
i am at home in east kingston with a
sleeping golden retriever
representative andrus
good morning home alone in my room in
salisbury
represented ford home alone in chester
representative leon
home with my three boys and husband
working remotely and a dog and a
partridge in a pear tree
representative sodie
i'm home with families in the house
they'll be
walking through every once in a while
thank you representative miler
i'm home alone in my office in contoco
new hampshire
representative luno
uh reporting here in hopkinton
representative shaw i'm home in
manchester my husband's walking back and
forth occasionally
representative cornell
home alone in manchester
representative tanner
home alone and georges mills with my
rescue dog raven
representative ellis uh representative
he
mary heath present here in manchester
and my husband is in the other room
representative mullen
i am here in the basement in bedford
alone
representative lay
i am uh present i am home alone in
jaffrey new hampshire
representative woodcock
good morning representative shaw i'm
here in center conway new hampshire with
my wife in the building and my
six-year-old birthday dog parking
good morning representative woodcock
i'll go back to representative allard
yes sorry about that uh i am here uh i'm
alone for the moment in my office uh in
pittsfield uh but my mother and my wife
are in the building
representative lycus
i heard her a minute ago
okay i'm here
um
in hudson my husband
tony lucas may be walking through from
time to time
except for representative bowen who
uh will probably join us soon thank you
well represent shaw i'll announce that
i'm
here rick ladd is here alone in
haverhill new hampshire
with my snoring cocker spaniel
and we're ready to go
i was getting to you
all right i thought okay
okay thank you very much everyone
thank you very much representative shaw
okay folks today on the calendar we have
uh for executive session this morning we
have two bills
hb 613 which deals with the special
education aid and the amendment we've
been um uh looking at here in terms of
uh insurance risk pool
and also hb607 which is our second
education savings account
piece of legislation
so starting out
we're going to start with hb613
i'm going to
do what i did the other day
i'm going to open this up to discussion
during this discussion period i will
absolutely take no
no uh motions for either
otp itl anything else retain etc
there are some issues i think which we
all need become more familiar with in
this bill
and that is the amending language for
the special education aid and for those
that are used to it this is used to be
called catastrophic aid
and it's
just a huge huge expense for local
school districts
and
i'm hoping that today we can discuss
uh the amendment which is being put
forth by
i will put for it forth but uh the
really the the people behind this have
been representative hill
and actuary support
trying to figure out a way that we can
avoid this really awful mess we're in in
terms of taking a huge part of the
catastrophic costs from
our operating costs uh the the state
coughs up uh very little of that and so
does the feds the the 40 we're supposed
to receive we've never received that in
the life of of that legislation
so i'd like to get on with this
and with the
support of the committee i'd like to
have
uh
the folks that are in the department of
insurance waiting to talk with us
and uh representative hill i understand
that and if they're able to be put into
the participant list right now and i
appreciate that
um so they they can also uh support this
is an amendment where we're looking at
and the amending lane the amendment was
sent out to people
it's uh zero three two five h
um it had a few technical questions or
five areas where there need to be some
slight changes i believe they're working
on that right now in ols
so representative hill
um you have uh
these folks uh
christian uh cinderella
from the department of insurance i hope
i'm i'm saying the name correctly
and the vice president of this actuary
firm that's located in kansas
so what would be the best order to
address as representative hill
good morning and good morning to the
house education committee
for the record i am representative greg
hill i
represent the town of northfield and one
third of the city of franklin
to answer your question chairman um
as far as i know both
experts
are standing by
hoping to be of service if we have
questions um
technical questions which i can't answer
um these are both actuaries firms one is
the department of insurance
and they did the preliminary actuary
work
and then we went for an rfp
um by this kansas firm
called
lewis and ellis and the vice president
of lewis and ellis is on the line as
well
so perhaps it might be wise than
representative that that you give a
brief overview of the bill first the
amendment
so that uh folks understand some of the
the language and and terms within it
and then we can get into questions or
for for our technical support as we've
done previously in many bills
uh happy to do that um
i will tell you that uh while this may
seem like a last-minute
bill uh this concept is years old um i
actually started working on this policy
idea
uh when chairman lad and i were sitting
on the education committee back in 2012.
just in the last two years it's been
revitalized with
with commissioner edelblut and
and we brought the concept to the new
hampshire department of insurance two
summers ago
um commissioner edelblut brought in the
uh
the
insurance commissioner
and uh and we were introduced to the
actuary from the insurance department
that is on the line now
they did very fine work and uh
and that led us to at the department of
education request a national nationwide
rfp for an actuary firm
to provide an analysis
of new hampshire's special ed claims
data and create tools to predict future
costs by each district
the vice president of the winning
actuary firm lewis and ellis is also on
the call today from her location in
kansas
i want to just let you know that in new
hampshire it's a well-known as chairman
lad just outlined
that school district budget committees
school boards and superintendents fear
unexpected high
special ed expenses arriving after
school budgets have been voted on and
fixed
the volatility of special ed costs
especially in smaller districts is a
huge concern
the data analysis done by our department
of insurance pointed out something
interesting
while districts can see important and
measurable volatility statewide the
special education costs remain fairly
predictable
all districts are aware of these
negative effects to a budget
and that's why 117 districts in new
hampshire currently have what some call
rainy day funds or non-lapsing capital
reserve funds
to self-insure against unexpected
special ed expenses
these accounts
statewide total about 6 million dollars
that averages 50 000 per district but in
reality the size of the accounts vary
enormously
up until now self-insuring has been the
single best way of handling the option
but some districts have rejected this
option
the amendment you have in front of you
simply enables school districts
themselves
to create and join risk pool
associations
which we believe will create a solution
to their fears and concerns of budget
busting non-reimbursed special ed costs
and much of the volatility
by creating a single budgetable expense
and for those districts who are
attempting to self-insure
we believe a collective risk pool is a
much better solution
the state of new hampshire through the
secretary of state currently authorizes
the use of what we what are called 5b
risk pools
5b because that is the rsa that covers
these instruments
currently reimbursing special ed
expenses is not a listed and approved
use of risk pools
in that rsa
this amendment first fixes that
municipal risk pools are a
well-recognized tool throughout the
united states i actually spoke with the
executive director for the national
association
of municipal risk pools about her
membership and while she knew of no risk
pools designed
for special ed costs she could only
confirm that none of her members of her
organization
utilize these tools
most of her members are health insurance
related and in fact the three municipal
risk schools currently in new hampshire
are also health insurance related
this amendment allows school district
superintendents to form a special
education risk pool association with as
few as five district
members
the associations will be
self-administered
the associations will have access to the
tools to predict costs and premiums
the associations will choose whether to
self-insure or apply for third-party
insurance or a combination of both
the associations can decide whether to
reimburse at one hundred percent or
eighty percent or any percentage they
choose
the associations for the most part
will control the rules they want by the
way their organizational documents are
drafted
the department of education for their
part continues to operate in the
adjudication of special ed claims
the department by this amendment will
have one additional responsibility
which is because of their duty to
maintain student privacy protections
and so they are required to issue rfps
for firms to update the claims data
that assures the cost predictor tools
can most accurate can provide most
accurate predictions of future premiums
for the school districts
with that i think i'll end my testimony
and offer to answer questions
i'm especially hopeful that you'll find
that superintendents will appreciate
this new option to help them create a
budgetable
insurance against budget busting
surprise without the need to build their
own single entity risk pools
thank you
thank you very much uh represent hill i
do have one question for you um
the premium costs that the individual
districts within one of these
associations would be paying you've
indicated can it be determined by that
particular association
eighty percent forty percent 100 percent
uh coverage
have you done any um calculations or as
the insurance uh department
or
any actuary uh firm here that has
identified what the actual premium cost
might be for a a a small a middle or
large school district
thank you for your question mr chairman
um so the answer
is it depends um unfortunately it
depends on who the membership of that
organization would be
each of the
each district is uh rated on their
experience
so they would um
there is a tool and that was the purpose
of the rfp
for the actuary firm in kansas to create
a tool to predict the the annual cost
for this coming year
and and so it depends on who the members
of our are of the association
the cost would be for each individual
district
and i think probably um that can be
better explained i know it can
by the actuary
we have in our possession now at the
department of education a cost predictor
tool
that took the claims i think it went
back to 2014
took the claims for each of the
districts
and was able to create a predictor tool
there's three different models within
this tool i'm told
and two of the tools
would allow all special ed costs
and the third tool
would indicate just the cat aid
risk
for the future
so it is um it is in this we have the
tool available now i guess is the answer
the short answer to your question and
and um so it would depend on which
community we're talking about
thank you are there questions from uh
represent milor
uh thank you uh thank you mr chairman
uh the question i have for
representative hill
is what conversations have taken place
uh with the special ed community
and the um superintendent's community
regarding this uh
novel idea thank you uh thank you for
your question representative um
as far as i as far as the special ed
community uh the only conversation that
i have had personally
um is with the coordinator at doe
um i am aware however that uh
commissioner edelblut has
floated the idea or talked about the
idea with uh with his collection of
superintendents that meet with him on a
regular basis
um whether that has included any special
ed coordinators i i don't know
a follow-up please yes you may yeah i
think i think this is uh important
because
obviously uh represent hill this is a
kind of a novel idea at least from my
perspective
uh has some potential
um my concern though is really in
dealing with those who
are actually
in the field
having to deal with the complexities
that you've outlined as far as the
funding et cetera so that would be my
concern regarding um
moving this forward of having some kind
of some time
for
those individuals to basically look at
this and uh to do some evaluation of it
so uh thank you for bringing this
forward to our committee
um
welcome i i do have a quick response to
that if that would be appropriate go
ahead
um so it would seem that uh the the
day-to-day operations of the of the
districts would remain the same
um
the only difference that would occur
would be
the reimbursement that takes place
um
either at the end of the year
once once the final payment is made by
the by the department of education and
we know what that unreimbursed amount is
um that's when the the work of the
association
would kick in to determine as
rep lead or chairman lad mentioned
whether it's 100 reimbursement of the
unreimbursed amount or whether it's 80
or whether it's 40
but the work of the the the day-to-day
work of the special ed community within
a district remains exactly the same
thank you uh representative lay
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative hill for taking the
question um it's a i'm just trying to
understand something here so on on page
two line eight
of the uh bill of the amendment i should
say
it references or just simply says is one
of the purposes is to minimize the state
regulatory oversight of the pool
so my question is simply uh why would
that be stated as a purpose and what
minimization
is planned here for state oversight of
this pool
so
thank you for your question
representative the idea
as far as the purpose statement goes
would be
we wanted uh the associations um which
are
are run by um at least five
uh superintendents on their board we
wanted them to be able to control
their product their their um idea of
whether to self-insure it whether to
take it to the market whether to do a
combination of both whether to pay it at
100 80 whatever percentage
we didn't want that to be anything that
was handed to them we wanted um the the
superintendents and and the associations
to um
to grab this because it affects them
more than it affects anyone else or any
other regulation at the state
so um
this is truly an an enabling piece of
legislation um and that enabling those
municipal risk pools to operate
on their on their own with very
very slight moderate
uh with very slight input from
or oversight from
the state part
the dollars themselves are going to be
held by the state treasurer but um but
how the program is designed from each
association standpoint would be up to
them that's the point follow-up mr
chairman yeshumi thank you um
so
is
clearly there would be in some degree i
suppose some element of risk in these
risk pools however they're designed is
it possible that these
uh pools in one of the various ways that
they're put together could actually fail
and if so who would be liable and
responsible then
so there's a couple of ideas there um we
obviously have the um
the risk pool that would or the
association that would create the
documents for this so
they have the ability to build in
um
any kind of a factor that they want to
within their within their uh 5b
organization schedule they can they can
create whatever they want inside that so
that level of risk
can be managed at their local level the
second part of this
and it doesn't apply to this amendment
which is why you don't see it referenced
here but there's another bill coming out
of the senate
that will be
a funding source that
um i've already spoken with the senator
and the idea is for that money to be
utilized as a
safety net um if if there's something
that um that creates a problem with the
numbers um
so that that's the idea there's a uh
there's a backup of fail-safe i guess
great thank you
thank you very much uh
represent woodcock
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative phil for taking my
question i have just very specific ones
uh three actually uh
the initial figure represents hill that
on page one of the cost of the average
special education per annum
is that the catastrophic cost or is that
the uh total student education special
education cost per student at seventy
four thousand dollars
yeah that that was just taken um that's
a doe number actually from um
i believe the entire special ed
um divided by um
what they
what they received
or no there was their total expenses for
that for the 2018 year
i think divided by the number of
students
follow-up mr chair yes
so so uh
hill so it's not that 74 000 strictly is
it's all the special ed youngsters
compressed into one figure and divided
okay i think so yeah it doesn't it
doesn't yeah
it wasn't meant to be a um
you know a specific
you know it's not down to the penny it
was a uh it was the total number right i
might be able to give you the numbers
that you used
well that's fine if i can follow just
clarify a little further if i may miss
the chair so i thought the bill when i
first read it and it's always kind of
interesting at least the amendment i
thought it was for to have oversight of
the catastrophic problems we don't
anticipate but yet your your price is
based on your figures based on all
students
um thank you for your for your question
um
the point is um that the association i
believe
can can decide each each uh association
can decide whether they are
uh targeting strictly the catastrophic
um what used to be called cat a right um
uh and and so that would be obviously a
much less cost uh to each individual
district so in in my head um
i would expect that there would be one
association that may do
nothing but cat aid and and there may be
districts that want to join that
association for that purpose at a lower
cost than trying to self-insure thank
you one more fall for me and i'll be
done mr chair thank you
uh representative one one last one you
talked about this is enabling
legislation so the opportunity for local
school districts to participate or not
participate uh and the pro one of the
parameters
is that it has to be a five school unit
to participate
as a group um but then on page 33 you're
talking about doe being the one that
that creates the creates the uh the uh
draft
yeah so i was wondering if if it's
enabling i'm sorry i lost you here if
it's enabling legislation
um and it's done by the five districts
why is d.o.e going oh yeah you're on the
screen sorry
why why are they gonna you jumped around
why are they going to be um uh
controlling that group
um purely thanks for your question
purely for the security
concerns
there are
this this rfp that the doe is going to
have to update periodically
does contain
specific information of uh concerning
student privacy and uh and so the doe
has that information it wasn't anything
that we wanted um each association to be
able to see
the information that comes from a
neighboring district or something like
that
okay thank you mr chairman thank you mr
hill you're more than welcome
representative tanner
i can't hear you are you unmuted
represent tanner
got it down now can you hear me now yes
okay uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative hill for taking my
question
um i know that um there's a difference
uh between the smaller districts and
also poorer districts and their and the
uh poverty rich or poverty property rich
districts and larger districts having
their own um like you said rainy day
fund the smaller districts aren't able
to to amass enough for
for example a special ed student who
comes into the district and is a hundred
thousand
out of district placement
um and they've talked about this this
pool i'm just wondering
if you see uh any issues
that would um create more inequality
among the districts uh by setting up
this enabling legislation and not in
other words um
the
the well-off districts will be able to
um
fund themselves and the smaller
districts will they be able to
will they be able to actually get the
money to get into this insurance pool
thank you for your question um and i
would have thought exactly the same
thing um until i received back from
caitlyn
at d.o.e uh the
the she was able to split off for me
by district the amount of money that uh
that of those 117 districts that have
created this rainy day fund
she's given me the snapshot from june
30th of last year
and it is remarkable
how um
how
these districts have uh created this
these pools of money um in their rainy
day funds i'll call them um
because there's no rhyme or reason that
shows uh a a poor district um can
operate any differently than a than a
wealthy district and i'll give you two
examples
um
so
uh
looking at it um
claremont uh claremont's able to set
aside 220 000 into the account
nashua has nothing in the account
manchester has two million something in
the account
franklin has a hundred and eighty
thousand in their account
laconia has nothing um it's all over the
board it's it's um you know there are
some districts uh here that that go down
to as low as uh
43.86 in their account um
so i'm not sure but i think
i think the short answer to your
question is
um all districts can't afford not to do
something like this
it's a much bigger concern when they
when they run into that cost that they
can't control um
this is this is much less cost uh
predicted to be and uh
and hopefully there is not a situation
where
a district can't afford to be in this
risk school
could i have a follow-up mr chair uh yes
one quick follow-up and then what i'd
like to do is that we've had some folks
uh that are professionals in this area
that have been listening to our
discussion
and i'd just like to ask them following
your your question your follow-up
question here uh representative tanner
if they have any
uh uh the
input to what we've been discussing or
information that we should um might want
to take under consideration represent
tanner go ahead with your question
uh yes and and thank you representative
hill for pointing that out i was more
concerned really with the
smaller schools like plainfield um
so what happens to the rainy day funds
after if they join this risk pool can
they still maintain their rainy day
funds
uh thank you for your question yes
absolutely um
there's no reason anyone has to join
an association they can keep going the
way they're they're going
there is also
no limitation i've already
checked on
this the specifics
or the statute that governs those rainy
day funds and it appears depending on
how it's drafted
at each individual district level it
appears that they would be able to use
those rainy day funds
as their premium
so-called premium for for the
association membership um and since you
mentioned plainfield i'm looking at it
with two hundred and
two hundred and thirty-five thousand
sitting in their
rainy day fund
thank you very much
uh
representative hill you have uh several
uh professionals out there one from the
department of insurance and and the
other from the firm in kansas
um
could you introduce them please
um sure you just didn't want to
pronounce uh
chris's christian's name right is that
what it was
so i just call him christian but
christian is uh is uh one of the lead if
not the lead actuary at the department
of insurance uh christian citarella um
is how i pronounce it
christian are you there
i am
and do in listening to our conversation
uh is there anything that you might add
from a technical perspective or might
clarify some points that have been asked
um no not necessarily um i was uh
representative hill approached me about
two years ago and uh along with
commissioner edelbut and just uh
asked whether this
concept was um were this risk to to uh
districts was an insurable risk and so
you know um i did a very what i would
consider a back of the envelope analysis
of it um this isn't my area of expertise
but in some ways
it's a very new product
as has been mentioned and so um
i did a like i said i did a back of the
envelope uh
you know estimation uh it does appear to
be
it does have the potential to be a
working
uh insurable model um i then
recommended that they find uh
folks
whose expertise
are closer to
this particular problem um i'm a
property and casualty actuary uh by
training and uh this type of risk um
lends itself more
towards the expertise of a what what are
called life and health actuaries uh so
you know because of the nature of of the
risk
it
probably would lean more towards uh like
a more more like a health risk than a
property or casualty risk
and so um
they
they put out the rfp and uh so i just
wanted to say uh
um
andrea rome who's on the line somewhere
from lewis and ellis
is a very qualified uh life and health
actuary and i've worked with the um with
her firm in the past and so i just
wanted to kind of lend a little
you know legitimacy or or
you know um credibility
to that firm and uh what and i did take
a look at what they produced and um the
tool does look really really good um
used uh several different uh actuarial
techniques for modeling um
does uh
lend credence to it and um
in the work that they produce so
if you have questions for me i'm happy
to but uh andrea is the person to talk
to
okay thank you very much chris and and i
do appreciate your willingness to come
forward today and assist us so i guess
what we will do next is if you could
hang loose and and maybe what we could
do is have andrea rome um
she is a panelist so andrea welcome to
uh
new hampshire
and uh do you have uh
anything you can add to assist us in
better understanding this legislation
yes absolutely and and good morning to
all of you and and thank you for
inviting me here today
uh so as was stated i'm i'm from louis
nellis we are an actuarial firm we've
been in
uh business ever since 1968. uh a.m best
regularly ranks us as one of the top
actuarial firms in the nation
so i'm coming to you from kansas city
right now
i want to talk to you a little bit about
the model that i built this is a cost
predictor
we use predictive analytics techniques
to
try and determine
these catastrophic costs by school
district
specifically the catastrophic costs
around the special education students
um
so i i did want to add that
there was some concern about the smaller
school districts because they
particularly get hit hard by um volatile
costs
a student could completely blow up
whatever they budgeted for special
education students
um so
i i think the plan to try and predict
these costs and also to create a pool to
cover some of these catastrophic costs
is helpful for the small school
districts
simply because it gives them more
financial stability than they would
otherwise have
we noticed when we were building the
predictive model that
it's
the prior year is often very predictive
the prior year catastrophic costs
a lot of times are very predictive of
what will occur
in the following
year but not always
and it's those cases where
the current year is nothing like the
prior year where you really your budget
gets blown up and
and you run into financial issues
um
hence this idea to maybe create a risk
pool so i'll stop there and i'm happy to
answer any questions you may have
thank you very much are are there any
questions
yes
so my question is whether she could
expand on the uh the idea of being able
to use
the predictor the cost predictor for
all special ed costs or just cat a
uh yes representative hill that's a good
question right now we have built the
model
specifically to predict cad a costs
we do
of the three different modeling
techniques that are in the cost
predictor
all three of them are focused on
predicting those catastrophic costs
there is one of the methodologies that
we've used that also predicts
total costs for sped students
but the model
the cost predictor is really focused on
the catastrophic
uh follow-up please mr chair
yeah one quick one from you greg then if
there's any committee members
yep um so i'm just trying to clarify
some of this um would it would it be
possible for a
um
an association one of the associations
that started up to be able to
accurately or or be able to predict
or know what the premium would be to a
district or group of districts if they
wanted to use
total
sped costs rather than just cat aid
would that be possible
it's possible with the tool to predict
total costs uh but again i would say
that this cost predictor tool is
primarily for cat a cost
thank you
um i have a question mr chair
oh let's see who who is leon and then
rep rep miler has had his hand raised
for a while so i'm not sure if that's
old or
um new or continuing
yeah i'll go first with representative
leon because she has not asked any
questions then we'll go to
representative milo who has had you know
a previous opportunity
are you thank you mister our mel you got
take your hand your your
okay i'll take care of it thank you yeah
okay
leon
well thank you mr chair and thank you
miss rome this is a fascinating tool and
i'm a former i'm an economist and former
options trader so
i'll try not to get too deep into these
questions with you
this sounds like a phenomenal model to
look at this risk is this something
where the more of these small districts
participate the better that they'll be
able to smooth those costs and
really be able to lower that volatility
year by year and district by district
yes absolutely and and that goes back to
your insurance principles of the more
people you have in the pool the more
likely it's going to tend towards your
average expected costs
um so if you can pool more of these
small districts together the more able
they're going to be to be predict uh
these sped costs
um
so yeah that's a that's a great thing to
point out
and if i may have a quick follow-up yes
you may
thank you mr chair um and are you were
you able to see the amount that these
districts had in their rainy day funds
and do you have any sort of
um judgment as to whether those costs
would cover on say some level of
coverage for these for these towns or if
it would simply be a separate allocation
that's something we did not look at was
the rainy day fund
it's something we could incorporate
going forward and look and see kind of
the range of results and if the rainy
day fund would cover
extreme cases moderately adverse cases
or
the average of what we'd expect
that would be fascinating thank you so
much
thank you very much uh are there further
questions of miss rome
not seeing any on my screen
representative hobson do you see
anything that
i don't no
well thank you very much to all the
specialists from from the insurance
company and out there in kansas uh we're
sorry your chiefs didn't do as well as
they
may have but they're up against a pretty
powerful quarterback
from florida
thanks so much
for the rest
thank you for the rest of the committee
right now
um
we don't have a motion on the floor but
i think there's still a little room for
some discussion
one of the
rep heath has her hand raised i don't
know if she can
represent heath thank you mr chair um
i this is a significant
um
ground shaking actually shift from the
way the department of ed has worked
for these costs with what we formally
know as catastrophic aid
i am extremely concerned about um
adopting such an amendment at this point
in time without um a hearing uh that
would address the concerns
we really need to delve into this at a
much deeper level and um unless we had a
hearing and and
um publicly advertise this i i really
think this is not a good
amendment to proceed with at this point
in time thank you mr chair
thank you
further discussion
uh rep leon has her hand raised and uh
representative miler
uh i i didn't hear who the first rep was
that you mentioned uh uh rep leon
okay we'll go represent mile or then
represent lyon look i would i would uh
thank you uh mr chair i would concur
with uh representative
heath's comment i mean
this is very intriguing
and i'm i'm interested in how this might
work
but
unless we can really hear from those
who would be participating in these
collectives
and those who would benefit from these
i really think
this takes a little more time
to look at this
big change i mean i i i i'm intrigued
by this
how it might
be implemented and that's my concern uh
mr chair
i think we i think it needs more time
here
thank you
thank you representative leon you were
the next person
uh thank you mr chair i do think that
there are some very interesting points
raised here and i would love to dig into
these details but to me it i don't see
where this impacts the day-to-day
operations of education in the state i
see this as a purely financial product
one that is exactly the kind of risks
that financial instruments are designed
to cover
and while we could have a hearing in
education i don't i quite frankly don't
think that we would be the appropriate
place for a hearing to dive into the
financial aspects of this especially
relating to actuaries and all of the
details that are involved i do know that
this if it does move out of our
committee we'll be going to finance and
i believe that they are the perfect
place to hear these financial details
because that is their bread and butter
we're policy and they have the expertise
to look at risk analysis models and
insurance modeling
thank you representative tanner
uh thank you for taking my question
while i thoroughly agree with
representative leon uh the small
districts up as i said before up in my
area have been kind of looking at this
um as a possibility
for a number of years now um they
they've talked about it and i do think
that there's a policy side to this as
well
um that needs to be
looked at um more in depth uh about how
it's going to
play out on
in these small school districts um how
the payments are made uh you know what
kind of
questions superintendents and business
managers will have
about the the initial setup of
the way it's um you know the
associations are put together uh how
people can leave the associations or not
that sort of thing so i would agree with
representative heath
that um
it's really intriguing
like i said uh districts in my area
small small districts have been looking
at this possibility
um i'd like to pursue it further but i
really
think that you know they would like a
chance to come in and ask their
questions as well so
um
that's that's what i have to say
thank you
um i i just like to go back to daily
day-to-day operations that uh we've
heard that that terminology used and
there's a district that's just south of
me
that had two
cad aid i you know we should be using
the word special education aid
but that that these two youngsters
appeared in the same year
and had not been enrolled the previous
year
and this is a small district with under
a hundred students in it
it was totally devastating
and
it it did impact their uh
operations
in terms of they were seeking dollars
from any avenue or venue they could find
within their budget to support this this
need which they're required by law to
provide
and they didn't they were not objecting
to you know you know the the need it's
just that it was a total financial
issue that you know meant either in in
their their their reserve fund the the
monies which they put aside in this
non-lapsing reserve they it was just
basically nothing there
uh they've never had the wherewithal to
put something into that account it's
probably one of those districts with 46
dollars and some odd cents
um so
it is a real pressing issue
and
i i
i think for it to continue i don't want
to see something like this die
uh we need to really look at a way to
get out of this this path we've been in
ever since i've been in the house and
heard about this it's been a question
and how do we fund this this special
education aid and and there's so many
unknowns
so
i'm i'm i would like to see
something occur i'm not objecting
necessarily to having hearings i think
what represent leon said is correct that
we're now recognizing by policy we've
got to do something
and this is the best uh idea that i've
seen come down regarding how we handle
catastrophic aid with developing
individual associations which is
enabling legislation you can take your
five or six or seven districts around
about one certain area where a child
might be bound
they usually move from one district to
another
when they either become unhappy with the
way it's been provided in past or they
they they have to move for economics
within the family
and so i i would like to see us you know
push this forward and have that
discussion within the committee which
looks for this type of discussion
education finance
and if they deem it necessary to put
this off for a year then i will respect
that motion but i i i think we'd be in
air if we tried to hold this for another
another go around
especially during covet
uh further
mr chair we have a hand raised from
representative leon and then
representative lay
thank you
represent leon
uh thank you mr chair uh representative
tanner i think brings up a good point
i'm not sure how many of her districts
are looking for a product like this
um
if if there are districts within within
her area that need this and potentially
one of the ones near chairman ladd is in
need of this that may already be five
districts who may choose under this
enabling legislation to further pursue
this on a policy basis i think that that
actually demonstrates the need and
because this doesn't force anybody to
take any particular actions
i think that this is an opportunity that
we owe to these towns we need to let
this go to finance so that they can work
through the details on it but i think we
owe them the opportunity to solve this
problem
thank you
representative lay
thank you mr chairman um would it be
appropriate that if this amendment were
adopted that this bill actually should
go to commerce as a second policy
committee because it does deal with
insurance and that's what commerce does
as well
before it goes to finance that's
question one
and then this my second question
is
if if this is beneficial and and it
seems like it has potential
what is the what is the benefit or what
is why
what would be the preference
currently now it seems to be to have a
number of these smaller pools why not
have a single statewide pool that any
district could enter into
represent lay you asked two wonderful
questions
thank you
and not necessarily questions the first
one is is very accurate in the past we
have had bills that need to go to a
second and a third committee and that's
very plausible and i agree this is uh
has to deal with commerce
and and uh it'd probably be apropos that
something like this occur
uh they're the ones that would be able
to delve into some of w where this is
coming from how we manage it
etc
more so than i think education policy
can i have heard nobody say this is
downright wrong
there's folks that have been raising
those questions which are legitimate
concerns
but we all recognize that catastrophic
aid needs to be
looked at
and for us to
put this into another small subcommittee
within
uh
our group right here i personally don't
think we're loaded with the
the expertise that this bill other
representative leon you i'm not
degrading your background but uh mine is
that of an educator of being a teacher
being a school principal
i would love to see something like this
occur i as an administrator
had
always looked at where can i steal some
money to support the ever increasing
costs on this side of the ledger
but it was robbing peter to play paul
and so
truthfully i would love to see this bill
float on to another policy-oriented
committee that had some other horses to
ask the questions that i think represent
leia is speaking to
further understandings here
i'll certainly defer to representative
leon
my expertise has been exceeded already
okay so i i want to ask uh
representative cordelli a question have
we received the updated uh version of
this bill yet
the the amendment we had an amendment
which was um i believe a zero three two
five h
and there were err there are five
um
corrections requested by representative
hill
um most of them are just you know pass a
single word here or there or a
typographical error
or inserting represented by its
superintendent
have you as has anybody seen this this
amendment yet
as amended
yes the question is
i i have not uh just looking through the
legislative email i have not seen any
additional amendment to this bill
okay i i i realize that one has been
submitted to try and correct that
um i i i would prefer to try if it to
have a motion which we dealt with the
most current amendment rather than this
and
ols i know is swamped representative
cordelli could you please contact ols
and find out what the status of this is
we'll do that
okay um so i'm not going to be accepting
a motion on this at this particular
point
so
i guess what we can do is that if is
there anything else that you know we we
don't have anything on on the
emotion made or on the table right now
we do have some other bills which we
have coming up
is there any discussion uh regarding
um
anything else we have i i initially when
i put this
um
schedule together i had at the bottom of
of tuesday a a note in parentheses it
said a committee of the whole to discuss
594 which is the building a aid bill may
follow the morning executive session or
at the close of the afternoon hearing if
time allows
um
that that is an issue that we did
discuss earlier um and we we did retain
one bill 214
and we were looking at 594 as possibly
um
trying to address some of the issues
that we see and that we can come to
grasp are in terms of a common
goal
to move 594 forward
i did have a
amendment for that that has been sent
out by
ols this morning and i ask that it be
sent to all committee members
uh i'll ask if anybody's received that
or seen it
okay
so what we can do now uh until
representative cordelli um
gets back with some information there i
think we can just take a short recess
here and um
sorry
yep are we okay out there
yeah tucker seconds that
okay so what we're gonna do is
um we'll take about 20 minutes here and
try to do some follow-up with ols and
come back my my uh time says about 1002
right now so how about if we come back
at 10 20. mr chair ralph has his uh
representative boehm has his hand raised
and and uh rep lekis does as well i'm
not sure
representative
yeah i just want to
mainly for representative shaw i am here
i've heard most of the testimony i did
my testimony in judiciary and and had
come here just what for the record i am
here and been here for a while
thank you i saw you join uh represent
okay ralph can you hear me yeah
okay
i think i'm i'm straightened out
electronically here too okay
thank you barb representatives do you
have uh a question or some input here
well i just um it was sort of question
comment i'm not sure which
um
as far as a statewide
one this it looks to me like it could
potentially grow to be one statewide one
if that's what
towns wanted to do am i right or wrong
on that
i i i don't have an answer for that it's
all conjecture right now uh it's it's
the those associations are locally
brewed and designed and
they decide how much they're gonna what
kind of premium they're gonna have and
maybe a wealthy district may have some
money still in that reserve rainy day
account and they use that to pay their
premiums or the difference between
you know the the premium and and what
the actual costs of this special student
may be
so um i i couldn't venture a guess on
that right now
uh mr chairman if i might yes
um i contacted ols and they're checking
on the status of that and will call me
back
okay
rep leon has a hand raised represented
leon
uh thank you mr chair it's uh to my i'm
speaking to the point of the
this growing to a statewide pool i think
that the way that it's written it has
the flexibility where it can grow to
whichever size is most most efficient
and competing pools can better serve
different needs so i think it's
fascinating i also do think that even
though this is my area of expertise this
is where i would be asking questions of
people who know this better which is why
i do think that it goes well to another
committee
yeah well that thank you very much the
other option which we can do right now
and i think i will do this is that we
had another bill to exact today
that we can jump around we always have
before
in our exec sessions uh hb 607 education
savings account
and then come back and resolve uh 613
following
607.
so
mr chair rep uh mullen has her hand
raised and i just saw rep mylar have has
his hand raised as well yes represent
mullen thank you uh mr chairman and
thank you representative hobson for
paying attention
um
i just do we have any information from
other places in the country where this
kind of risk pool is being used
i do not have any information myself on
that no
i mean i know that we're uh just as a as
an aside i know that we're referring to
this as ground bait breaking in new
hampshire is it groundbreaking
nationally or
i i mean i i just um i'm just looking
for some
sort of backup data if there is any
north carolina is using that
north carolina is okay but we don't have
any current data on how it's going in
north carolina
um no
not at the moment i'm wondering if um
well
would we want to bring in anyone to for
testimony on that rep um chairman lad
well the the areas this is one of those
categorical grant areas that we have in
education and we have several others too
as well you know building building aid
as a category grant area a special
education cat aid is a categorical grant
area and there's also in the in the past
been discussions whether we should do
the same thing for transportation
um
those areas are above and beyond our
adequacy funding formula and there are
states though that have incorporated
some of these aspects of these cat
categorical grant funds into their
funding formula
so we in looking at that
this is a complex issue when you start
looking at other states because you have
to look at their total funding
formula for education and where the
monies are parked uh there are some
states that believe that for example
school building aid is part of the basic
requirement for an adequate education
we've always had that outside
seeing that back in 2008
when we looked at it through the joint
legislative oversight committee on
costing and education
building aid was being funded
and so that by statute so there was no
need to include it but other states have
so as far as this this area of cad aid
i think it'd be very difficult to
mimic another state unless we looked at
their whole structure of funding
and
i think we are in a groundbreaking area
here i have not done any research on
this so i want to be very clear on that
um
and but i am very concerned
a rep miler and rep cordelli um and then
rep tanner
yeah okay thank you and thank you mr
chair
i think there are several issues here
one is is the policy question
the issue is is this a good idea
and i think that does reside with this
committee
the second question then if this is a
good idea
how then might it work
and this goes back to representative
lay's comment
of moving this then if we think it from
a policy standpoint it's a good idea it
then should go probably to commerce
i do not believe that this should go
directly to finance
i mean finance has a lot to deal with
and frankly
they don't have the time
to deal with the intricacies of this
kind of a concept
i would i would really caution this
committee
to move forward this in a real rapid way
because
as i said before i think we need to hear
from those who are going to have to
implement this out in the field and we
just haven't heard that that voice yet
to this morning
so i think we should be cautious as we
move forward on this thank you
representative uh was tanner next or was
cordelli
okay
now we have um rep luna
also
go ahead uh thank you mr chairman um i
agree with some of the previous speakers
that
commerce probably would be the best
place to follow up on this
they have more expertise in this area
and can hold
public hearings
that would
better get the information that's needed
and i think that there's no reason to
hold it further in this committee
thank you
uh represent tanner
um i withdraw my question oh thank you
in in the past we have had these bills
go
not not this type of bill but we've had
bills go to health and human services
we've had it go to children family law
which are follow-up policies where
issues
dealing with things such as medicaid and
schools can be better handled with the
expertise that's on the other committees
and i i also concur i believe the place
this bill should go next is to commerce
another policy committee and i like the
idea there they can
um better
hear it and discuss it then i think we
are
we are not really oriented around some
of the questions which we're hearing
here
um it it's at the beginning if this if
i'd known about this at the very start
of this i probably would have vacated
this bill to them
um where where
it belongs um like we vacated one of our
bills to finance where we were just
dealing with changing a dollar amount it
had nothing to do with policy this does
have something to do with policy however
i and we it's
at this point in time we've heard it
ourselves not from the public's
perspective
but i i think the involvement the next
step would be commerce uh
can i um
it's sorry chairman lad uh rep luno
withdrew his hand
um rep cordelli wants to be recognized
and i also just received the amendment
via email so go ahead cor uh rep
cordelli
oh i'm sorry chair loud you you
recognized it
don't you know who i am
thank you uh to both chairman um
uh i uh i had not seen the amendment but
just heard back from uh the head of ols
that it was in its final review and
should be available to us within a half
an hour so
maybe uh
uh chairman hopson knows more than uh
ols does at this point
i'm gonna forward it to you apparently
people do know who i am now
just kidding here you go
it's coming by email should i send it to
the whole committee or
yes it came to my book in fact i've
already sent that message to ols today
that it be when it's done to be sent to
everybody on the committee okay so you
know this bill
any bill that is
sent to another committee uh as
i recommended to the speaker earlier
this year with one bill the speaker
makes that decision and it will would go
to that particular committee where it's
better
going to have a better hearing um so
we have about a half hour here
we can and i want folks to have an
opportunity to look at that amendment
and then
note where those changes are i think the
changes are basically the same page and
line numbers that
i sent those changes out to folks
yesterday i believe
it's all coming together here
to look at
um so at this point in time it is uh
10 15
or thereabouts um
i'd like to uh
you know recess this for about 15
minutes where everybody can
have you actually receive this on your
computer representative cortel cordelli
no
reps and hobson have you received it
uh yes
oh you know what the uh
i'm sorry uh yes i received a copy from
representative hill and i've asked him
to forward it to the education committee
um
and to gen 4 our assistant so it should
be coming momentarily
represent miler have you received it you
know if you're there
represent luno have you received it
i don't see anything in mind
okay
representative woodcock has his hand
raised
go go ahead represent woodcock
thank you mr representative just a quick
question i'm sitting here listening to
all this um
it's relative so i'll ask it
they said that they had a predictive
model to help the the actuaries to
develop this piece i wonder in that
predictive model um was there any
speculation on what a premium would be
i'm just curious what a premium might
cost a school a school or small school
or school
just random idea that's all
we sort of got around to that question a
little bit when we were talking about
the levels of premiums the
percentage-wise
of what it would assume or take the cost
of those unpredicted costs
um
but we never did discuss the you know
what the
average premium might be
yeah i don't think that's capable we're
capable of doing that seeing that the
size of the association would be a a
definite impactor
um the you know when we try to get you
know a sick lead bank within a school
district the larger number of
teachers in that district
really really do support
costs in the amount that have to be
contributed
and that also goes when we're looking at
counties trying to get together and find
a cheaper way for utilities when you
join as a as a total group you can knock
down your costs first only two or three
getting together so
i i don't think we have that information
represented woodcock um
that's right thank you thank you
residents here appreciate it yeah
mr mr chairman i i just did receive
information
uh from jane bergeron
who is the uh executive director of the
special ed coordinators and she has said
that there has been no conversation
with the coordinators
coming from the they meet with the
department coordinator on a weekly basis
and she said this is all new to them
that they've not seen this at all
they've not looked at the amendment
and there is some concern about the
impact
that this could have without them having
a chance to really look and study this
uh in a definitive kind of a way i
thought the committee should know that
thank you mr chair thank you
oh mr chairman
has her hand raised
if i may mr chair represent
thank you mr chair
so
it is it is un unknowable right now to
price the premiums because there are too
many variables and too many
uncertainties there is absolutely no way
that we could have any sort of useful
premium what we do know is that there
are already districts that are doing
this in the least efficient way possible
these rainy day funds are the most
expensive way to do this they have the
highest opportunity cost yet it is still
valuable enough for enough of these
these districts that they are doing this
in the most inefficient way possible
this is something that that i think
it will not impact the day-to-day
operations this is something where
instead of having an inefficient rainy
day fund we can have something more
sophisticated and provides a better
value so i think i think that this is a
phenomenal tool what i did was price
risk that is what i did on the options
floor and i am so excited about this
opportunity and i can't wait to see what
commerce has to say because they know
these details better than we do
thank you
thank you very much
uh i'm going to take a break here for
uh
15 or 20 minutes here to look at that
amendment read it over i haven't had a
chance to look it over and i would
advise everybody to take this recess
get something out of your refrigerator
get a cup of coffee look it over please
and we'll come back in about 20 minutes
so it's right now it's it's 10 20 we'll
come back at 10 40.
so everybody okay with that
yep thank you
take your mid-morning break
we'll be back at 10 40. thank you
so
this
uh
so
hello this is tommy lucas
looks like it's working now
i'm helping alicia with a problem on her
computer could someone say some unmute
and say something so i can tell if her
sound's working please good morning tony
thank you i got it working
i can't answer that right now
hey
you me
okay debbie can you see me and hear me
yes i can
okay i think i got finally got this
thing working now if i can figure out
how to mute myself again
i think sometimes uh when you have two
devices
on your you know within each other if
you're not muted it'll when they're both
yeah i i knew that was the problem
that's but i couldn't figure out how to
shut this one off because i'm not using
it it's 10 40 and it's time for us to
continue
i hope everybody had a chance to get a
cup of coffee or a glass of water or
throw down a donut or two
okay
okay so here we are um dealing with the
and we've got quite a discussion here
and on the amending language uh i i
think it's now time we're
because we do have the other bill to
this morning as well
to you know to uh move forward
uh and uh get emotion on the floor so
i'm going to
recognize represent leon
thank you mr chair uh i would like to
move house bill 613 with amendment
2021-0356h
as ought to pass as amended
is there a second
the motion would be to adopt the
amendment oh
to adopt the amendment
oh sorry i knew
so i moved to adopt the amendment um 356
each
at the correct way to state that
so there was a second from was that you
represent allard yes it was okay thank
you very much
okay so we have a motion on the floor to
approve the amendment for 613
discussion
represent myler
thank you mr chair
this is unfortunate that we have this at
this point in time uh this is uh
an amendment that has come in at the
11th hour
it has significant implications
uh for
uh special education funding and how we
do it
uh the concept
there may soon be some some relevance
for that concept but we clearly have not
had an opportunity
to really ferret all the issues out here
and i think it's premature and
unfortunate because uh
although i may agree with the concept
once we
hear all of it
i can't vote for this at this point in
time unfortunately because
of uh it being rushed through
and i don't think it's a i don't think
it's
i don't think it's appropriate
for us to move this without
understanding the full impact of the
policy here
we can have somebody else look at the
issue of risk fuel and insurance and all
that other stuff this is not going to go
to finance this is a second bill that's
going to probably go to commerce
but i think we need to have a full
disclosure
of the policy implications here for sped
funding
i would really encourage you not to vote
this but we should retain this bill
and have more time to look at it
frustrated thank you mister
thank you representative uh
uh uh representative a late land you
didn't have it you made the motion so
you should have an opportunity to
speak to your motion
uh thank you mr chair
i recognize that this amendment did come
in um to us at this late date however i
believe that this policy is already
implemented currently we have talent we
have districts across the state that are
in self-insuring for the same exact
exact risk the policy already is to
address these risks through an insurance
system however it's the expensive
and high opportunity cost self-insurance
policy at this point this allows the
towns an opportunity to find a more
cost-effective method in order to
address these risks that they as a
policy already addressed i believe that
this this does fit with the current
policy and the current implementation
and it's simply a matter of financial
management and i believe that moving
this to commerce is the correct move at
this point thank you
thank you very much uh representative uh
see who we rep mullin
representative mullen thank you mr chair
um
with all due respect my uh my issue here
is not necessarily with the policy
though i would say that uh i don't feel
that i've had an adequate opportunity to
hear information to even know whether or
not i agree with the policy or disagree
with the policy but my concern
and it is a grave concern is with the
process that has been used uh this
morning because i feel a responsibility
to every one of my constituents to be
able to go back and explain to them what
has happened here this morning and
without an adequate opportunity to have
a hearing on the amendment and an
opportunity to be able to discuss this
and ask questions further i don't feel
that i'm in a position where i could
even uh
venture a guess as to whether or not i
agree with the policy or not and
uh as i said i have grave concerns about
that thank you
represent like us
yes
i'm not sure
if we had a public hearing and we
discussed all this and everything if
we'd be any farther along than we are
now
because most of us
don't actually understand all this stuff
in great detail
and it seems to me that the policy
basically is
yes schools ought to be able to have
an insurance
form
that they can enter into
and all those details and all those
things that need to be gone through and
looked at and all that stuff should be
done with commerce people who really
know what they're doing and not
education and our job is to say
yes this is needed here take it and
do whatever with it please
thank you represent uh lay
thank you mr chairman uh
yeah i i'm
disappointed here i suppose
i do believe that this needs
further study
the implementation and the implications
of this
we don't know at this point
we have not heard from superintendents
we have not heard from any of the
financial managers within the school
districts themselves we have not heard a
word from the uh communities
that would be directly affected those
requiring this aid um and benefiting
from this sort of aid
there may be no impact on them that that
may be the case but we do not know that
yet
and while i recognize that this is a
financial instrument
financial instruments
almost always
carry potential policy and social
implications they do not exist in a
vacuum
they carry policy and social
implications and that is the job of this
committee
is to examine and
and understand what those implications
possibly could be before we move this
forward into
the the into commerce where the
financial pieces themselves can be
looked at so
i i feel like this is a derogation of
duty or dereliction of duty on the part
of this committee and i i find that that
somewhat sad
that we would do that so i will
reluctantly vote against the amendment
and uh vote against the bill because i
think it should be retained and we
should be examining it um more closely i
don't see what the immediate rush is on
this
um we could take the time we should take
the time that's the job of this
committee that's the job of education
and educators thank you
represent boom
thank you
not passing this bill or an amendment
faculty will kill the bill for this year
which something we don't want to do
and as for amendments for hearings
when
have we ever had a hearing on an
amendment when we're
when we're executing a bill that's
we don't do that we have amendments for
bills when we do exact and that's always
happened so
this is something we need to do if if
this was going nowhere but to pass yeah
then i wouldn't be for it but it's going
to a second and maybe even a third
committee where all this stuff can be
hashed out so
let's move on thank you
representative shaw did you have your
hand up
we have um
yes
i did sorry
um
i just i just
i just i embrace this idea there's no
doubt about it we this this could
probably be a very very significant
change
uh to our districts and and to the the
funding of of the catastrophic aid and
i
but i agree
completely with uh
uh representative lay
we this bill is screaming retention
if you want to do something right and
have a grip on it and really understand
what's coming out of our committee which
is the way we've always done things in
the past is to really
study it and retain it and then
after we understand it and we get the
impact
statements from the superintendents and
from everyone that's going to be dealing
with this
uh
i i have no idea what my city would
think of something like this and and i
don't feel right
passing something that i don't even know
what my city would want to do with it or
my superintendent so i think that
retention would be a much better idea
and so what if it goes to next year
what's one year what difference does it
make if it's going to be beneficial for
30 years down the road then one year is
not going to make a difference and
and i
appreciate you letting me speak thank
you
thank you representative woodcock
thank you represent lad um
and i admit upfront that i'm a novice
when it comes to
moving bills through the house
but i i got to tell you
i'm a little just
amazed here
january 26th we had the hearing i took
three pages of notes on a two-page bill
that you and my friend representative
allen put in
and your comment was this bill is not
fully developed yet it's not plausible
that's your comment back in january 26th
20 days later 20 days later i get a bill
yesterday at six and a half pages last
night that i'm trying to understand i
get to the first screen we know it's
about cash flow began i think there's a
need to do this i think there's a need
to do this just not this way it's to me
it's a whole brand new bill uh mr
chairman and and i'm and i'm
you know i have a hard enough time i
understand these things that it is and
then when it comes on like this a day a
day before if we had 20 days to look at
it that that makes me nervous i'm just
figuring out 35 and 65 percent and two
and a half and three and a half percent
and you're 20 80. i finally get my hand
on all that and you bring an entirely
new bill
so i would appreciate the fact of it
because i think it's needed but i sure
would like the idea to have everybody
talk more about it so we can understand
it more fully and be lost on a bill i
heard 20 days ago
thank you mr chairman representative
tanner
thank you mr chair
um
as i've stated before you know some of
the small districts in my floaterial
have uh been talking about this so i am
really really interested in supporting
this bill
however
as everybody before me has stated i
haven't had a chance to go back and talk
to the people in those communities
to see
if this is what they envisioned if
they had some
ideas about it if there's going to be
some unintended consequences
with passing a bill like this with the
payment in special ed or with
contracting with services
is the insurance company like a health
insurance company going to decide
whether things are necessary
are they going to decide whether they're
going to pay the premium or the payment
out to the schools or not
there are so many questions with this
and people have talked about it already
i thoroughly agree with what
representative shaw said and
representative lay i would like to see
more time spent with this
get some people in from special
education get the people from my
district in to talk about it have a
chance for us to go back and talk to our
constituents about it
this is a complicated
complicated um
policy and uh to just throw something
like this at us at the last minute
um and again with possible unintended
consequences
as much as i want to want to pursue
something like this
i can't vote for it ought to pass i'll
vote for it to retain but not ought to
pass thank you
thank you
further questions
or statements
okay i'm going to go ahead then and have
uh the clerk call
the role please
and the motion on the table is to
approve
the amendment 2
uh and the amendment number madame clerk
is which number 20356h
thank you
representative cordelli
yes
representative baum
representative bone
representative allard
yes
representative lakes
representative moffat
yes
representative hobson
representative andrus
yes
representative ford
representative leon
yes
representative saudi
representative miler
[Music]
no
represent luna
representative shaw no
representative cornell
no
representative tanner
representative heath
the afghan mute
no thank you mr chairman
uh yeah speaking of farmington uh matter
of fact i want to budget representative
mullen
no
representative lay
representative woodcock
no
representative baum
i don't see him on the list he must be
dropped off by a representative vlad
yes
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
two one two three four five six seven
eight ten nine
okay the motion passes
with ten to nine uh for the amendment
now do we have a
motion represent
yes please um thank you mr chair i would
like to move house bill 613 with
amendment as amendment not to pass as
amended
thank you very much is there a second
second
uh that was represented allard thank you
yes
further discussion
not see any madam clerk please call the
roll
representative cordelli
yes
representative phone
representative allard
yes
representative lakes
representative moffat
yes
representative hobson
yes and i did just get confirmation that
representative boehm lost his internet
so okay
representative andres yes
representative ford
yes
representative leon
representative
saudi yes
representative miler
no
representative bluno
representative sean no representative
cornell no
representative tanner no
representative allison
i'm sorry representative heath
[Music]
no yes
representative sue mullen no
representative lay
no
representative woodcock
representative vlad yes
10 9
you very much the motion uh
or the bill passes uh will there be a
minority report representative miller
yes there will be and uh representative
lay will do that report
thank you very much
um and the majority report will be done
by representing leon
yes thank you
you're welcome um going on to the next
bill
uh
hb607
this is the education savings account
bill one of them
so i'm going to turn my book to that
bill
represent cordelia do you have a motion
uh yes mr chairman um i would like to
move uh retain on hb 607 and speak to my
motion
well let's have a second here first
represent like this
[Music]
representatives did you make them a
second
[Music]
she must be having audio problems oh
jeepers okay
i got no problems i kept hitting unmute
and it wasn't unmuting but now i'm
unmuted and yes i second the motion okay
thank you okay representative uh
cordelia would you like to speak to your
motion please
thank you uh after the or since the
hearing i have talked to the prime
sponsor
representative virgo on this bill
and he recognizes that there were a
number of
valid
concerns and comments
made during the uh hearing
and so uh he is in uh agreement that um
we should uh hold on to this bill and do
some further work on
it so that is the reason for my retain
motion
is there further discussion on the
representative cornell
i was just wondering if before we vote
on bills i thought we were going to get
updated numbers of how many opposed or
supported the bill because i know i got
many many emails about this bill so
if we had updated numbers of opposing
and supporting
foreign cornell during the hearing
process
this is the executive session and there
are no people testifying on this at this
time
why do you mean testifying i meant how
they can go online and click oppose and
support
that that's not part of the executive
session
okay
welcome back representative boom
yeah thank you i'm sorry i missed that
my internet went down i guess i don't
know might be something local
well thank you uh oh i think it's
happening all over the state frankly
i've had the same problem yes it is
occurring up here as we rebooted my
cable motor anyway it went down
it went down at the wrong time but i'm
back
thank you may i add something to what uh
you just told representative cannell
actually on this bill
uh
there was like zero zero that came
through on the uh to the to the uh to
jennifer this morning and she said that
uh they think there was some kind of a
glitch in the in the system because
nothing came through
support or or opposed or anything and
and so they're looking into it
well um
i called jen this morning i believe that
because it's executive session
uh we wouldn't be getting any of that
information but i'm not
uh so i called jen to tell her that she
was concerned and thought there was a
problem jen did you want to um that's
that's exactly correct i
on our dashboard it just um
it doesn't read whether whether it's an
executive session or a public hearing
when i saw zero
it was just completely my mistake for
not double checking to see that it was
an exact session so everything is fine
on that side we shouldn't have expected
any data
on those and gcts has
actually just since this morning
improved what our screen looks like on
this side so that um that confusion will
pop up again
i'm sorry rep shaw i should have told
you i wasn't sure uh that i didn't know
that you were on that email as well
so
just just to clarify for everybody in an
executive session we do not read off
those supporting and against
this is
this is our decision now this is a
meeting of this committee
and that's why everybody has the
opportunity to voice whether they're
supportive or against during that
committee but to go back and do the
hearing process and
it's just not the way it's ever worked
we have the opportunity to really exact
any bill that we've heard at any time
based with the notes that are in the
calendar so represent lay i see you have
a finger up there
yeah
thank you mr chairman i mean i think
representative cornell was simply asking
to go back into the record just as uh uh
to just be reminded what those numbers
were just as we could and we often do in
executive session we ask for um
a reminder or uh
going back and looking at um some piece
of testimony uh just to remind us what
it was i mean that's not out of order i
think that's all she's asking here is
just what it was just what the number
was at the end of the at the end of the
hearing there it's i i fully understand
nothing gets added in terms of the exact
session so that that's a fair question
and that's the way it it should work uh
if during our discussions at any time
somebody wants to ask that question the
data is available
but there's nothing going to be
available as a result of people calling
in on the executive session that's the
point
okay
yes
thank you um i did
i
i took the numbers on that was the
median of the ninth and i have i have
the numbers that testify the numbers in
favor number against the number neutral
that you gave us at that point
um in my notes here so i could i could
clarify that for representative cornell
if you like
well we're we're now is she talking
about the previous bill or this bill
this bill
okay
you're talking 607 that's fine we can
get that information
well i i have we have 16 testify
36 in favor 658 opposed to neutral
okay are there is there further
discussion
uh representative your hand is up is
that are you you're you're not
i did are you recognizing me mr chair
well you see you you yeah yeah i have it
up on the on the participant side as
well uh just a brief thing i just the
only reason i think it's worthwhile or
um to ask what the numbers are is
because the the uh registering supporter
opposition i believe is open until
midnight uh
of the day of the hearing and so while
the hearing we had a number at the time
of the hearing but there may be
additional supports or oppositions to a
bill that come in up until midnight and
so i think it's always useful to just
get that at the final sort of tally
that's all um because it is open in in
you know in normal times the blue sheets
would be collected and that's it it's
done but apparently digitally it's open
for a number of hours afterwards that's
all thank you
representative allard
uh thank you mr chairman yet just just a
point uh i
like representative cordelli uh i too
have had
long conversations with the bill's prime
sponsor and uh i very much support
retention
further comments represent miler
yes i'm going to vote no on this
i i believe that this bill
does not deserve to be retained
we have house bill 20 which we're going
to be looking at later in this week
which i think is the primary issue
dealing with vouchers
and this particular bill i think is just
way out there and i i don't think it
deserves to be retained thank you very
much thank you
uh represent like us
can't hear you you need to unmute
got it
uh the thing about this bill is it's
just enabling legislation
and
i don't suspect very many towns are
going to go for this
but
there may be the few i can think of a
couple who only have a very small
elementary school and after that they
have to tuition out their kids for most
of everything anyways and they might go
for this just to say that way
instead of trying to decide where all
their kids are going to go
the parents can decide where to send
their kids after like fourth grade i
know there's one that just is k through
four
so
um
that's really all it's for i don't see
otherwise many towns taking this up but
it should be available for those who do
want to do it
thank you very much
i
represent shaw
yes
um
the
towns can already do that
because i know in candia even though
they have a a
a distinct um
or they have one school that they send
them to they have in their
own school board charter that the
parents can
appeal to the board and that the child
can go to a different
school so i think this is unnecessary i
don't think we need to retain it
thank you
are there is there further discussion
represent layer your hand is still up
technologically are you have a question
now i'd like to just offer my comments
just very briefly which is that um i
also would oppose retention i think this
bill should be uh uh itld at this point
um there are so many problems with the
bill there's no fiscal note whatsoever
the prime sponsor himself could offer no
insight into potential costs um even in
his own town the bill i'm just going to
name a couple of things i mean the bill
says that um uh
the monies can be used for private
schools but current private school
students are not eligible uh the prime
sponsor couldn't figure that piece out
there's nothing about how to define
education services providers there's no
surety bonds for those providers
and i thought the most interesting and
and probably uh uh
i won't say dan well the mo the most
interesting comment was simply when the
prime sponsor was asked can i pay my
sister to serve as a tutor and the
answer was yes
regardless of whether my sister has any
capability or abilities whatsoever uh to
do so so i think this bill is it's it is
it is light years from being ready for
prime time and uh should not even be
retained the fact that we are willing to
retain this bill but we are not willing
to retain the prior bill um i think is
is is not a very uh
positive commentary upon um
the actions of this committee today
thank you
thank you representative
oh we have a um
here we go thank you mr chair um i just
want to concur with representative lay i
think this bill has so many issues um
and just as as a member of the finance
division two committee i certainly um
would find it confusing and um
would be tracked from um work that we
really need to get done i i just don't
think it's worthy of a lot of attention
thank you
are there is there further discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
representative cordelli excuse me excuse
me the the motion is
to be obtained
to retain 607.
right
representative cordelli
yes
representative vaughn yes
representative allard yes
representative lakes
yes
representative moffat
representative hobson yes
representative andrus
yes
representative ford
representative leon
yes representative soti
yes
representative miler
no
representative luno
representative shawn no representative
cornell no
representative tanner
no
representative he
representative mullen no
representative lay
no
represent woodcock
representative glad
yes
11 9.
thank you very much madam clerk
um
at this point in time we've done the
bills that we are have on the docket for
this morning
uh 613 and 607. uh the next bill we have
come up is a hearing on hb 608 which
would be the
a school funding bill uh so that will
start at 12 30. so until that time we're
going to
recess committee work till 12 30
as scheduled in the calendar for the the
hearing
mr chair
yes
yeah thanks very much um just a point of
information on 608 uh do we have a
fiscal note um on that and do you have a
town by town
no
okay
what what happened on the vote that
my internet got lost on what was the
vote it was 10 to 9.
thank you
representative
we will have a minority report on uh
and uh i'll get to you on who's going to
do that report
okay now who was doing the minority
report now for six one
three uh uh representative lee
that's that's correct thank you on a
point of procedure
the motion to retain i don't think is a
dispositive motion right
yes right
so there's no there's no there's no this
is no report no report we just retain it
and committed right yes correct right
yeah i was just trying to get you know
the 11 to 9 here yes we don't need a
any kind of report here
well thank you very much and we'll open
this thing back up at uh 12
30. thank you good enough thank you
foreign
me
okay
so
foreign
okay
so
foreign
c
so
thank you
foreign
so
yes
this
so
foreign
this
so
okay
finished
so
hey
change
yeah
thank you
foreign
me
so
yes
foreign
this
so
okay
foreign
so
okay
foreign
hey
so
to
this work
[Music]
so
okay
closers
hi deb
hi
who is it
i'm back oh mike moffitt okay sorry oh
there we are okay
is that you god
did you have a good lunch everybody
oh it was a great lunch the dog got half
my sandwich
had it on the table i went out to the
kitchen came back and the sandwich was
gone
well it's mardi gras
give up coffee for like tomorrow
representative my wife is happy that you
provide an opportunity for shovel snow
during lunch hour
[Laughter]
well you know we didn't get that much
snow we got a lot of rain and sleet and
and it's really pleasant up here right
now so
it's a short-lived storm
representative woodcock how much did you
get
um
oh wait can't aren't you neighbors with
well he's oh no i'm comfortable i come
from havel he lives in haverhill it's
just the wrong state
oh okay
for some reason i remember saying you
saying you could see his house or
something i don't know
it's a dud down here there's nothing the
roads are clear
i know it was icy this morning though it
was yeah it was
yeah
i can see why they called off school
it's all ice here and the trees are
falling
are they oh boy
where are you representative allan i
forgot pittsfield
okay canada yeah that's where you're
that it's the same in raymond and candia
too
uh and
we're we're high up on a hill we're
about a thousand feet here so
um
that may have something to do with it
but you up on apple hill
or upper hill no we're we're on the
opposite side a
place called tilton hill
oh i know where that is
well jim if you're taking the job at the
cold region center here in hanover you
wouldn't have to worry about all that
ice
i know i know
you want to check on a printing for me
we had a state rep visit here in loudon
a couple years ago and uh he said it's
so beautiful up here in the north
country and i said
loudoun is not the north country
haverhill is the north country well no
april's just the upper valley that
really get the north country you got to
go to pittsburgh
marksville whitefield jefferson
wolfton
groveton yes
it is beautiful they don't get out much
like where are those
oh it's beautiful up there
i my four years at plymouth i
got a lot of friends at
in the north country and they're still
friends of mine and i'm always up there
jefferson and
up that way i love it well
representative woodstock is from conway
yes north country
but it's it's it's interesting when you
travel up there because you know you if
you start in in
littleton or or berlin or gorham about
every 20 minutes up the road there's
this little town that's there
and there it's all self-sufficient i
mean it's it's really it's really
charming i like the north country a lot
what's so charming about conway it takes
you about an hour and a half just to get
through it
you
so representative la our chairman ladd i
understand i don't know if it was uh you
or
or representative miler that has like an
annual
summer barbecue at their house that i
hear
no it's not me
i don't think it's a mile right now i'm
gonna
oh i don't know where i heard that from
so i don't know where you got that but
that doesn't happen
well the well the former executive
counselor up there uh burton used to
have this massive uh summer fling at his
house up in well he was from what
bathroom monroe right
just right across the river
yeah and it was it was a really a very
nice affair very you know it was
bipartisan and
it was it was a fun event
ray was a great player again ray was a
great guy
i helped representative burton in 1978
uh it's the only campaign he ever lost
[Laughter]
that's
the primary to a guy named paul mayette
and
in 78 very interesting in 78 speaking of
new hampshire history because governor
thompson was beaten by you gallon and in
the same election uh tom mcintyre was
beaten by gordon humphreys new hampshire
voters
in
the ticket
flip the ticket is that what you said
split
ticket
they kicked out thompson and they
brought in gordon humphrey go figure
okay folks i think we got to get on task
here we'll have our geography lesson
later on
um of our street rip uh
chairman ladd i have representative baum
attending by phone his internet is down
so i'm should i promote him to panelists
even though there's a phone number is
that okay well that that's fine if you
know whom who you know you know it's
that that is represent boom we're not
taking any action here we're hearing
right now right right sure actually it
doesn't look like i can so never mind
okay
okay so
um let's go ahead and open up this
afternoon session and i've got to read
our
our little spiel here
get that out
okay um
i like to open up the session here that
we're dealing today with a hearing for
hb608
prior to getting into the hearing i
shall read the chairman's script
as chair of the house education
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and and in accordance with house rule 67
in the governor's emergency order number
12 pursuant to executive order 2020-0
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the education committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600
or email hcs
dot ledge.state.nh dot u s
in the event of the public
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
uh
a meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us this afternoon jennifer four our
committee researcher please note that
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by our clerk
taking the role
roll call attendance
when each member state would each member
state their presence
please
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required on the right
to know law under the right to know law
okay thank you very much uh madam clerk
do you have the roll call there
i do
thank you
representative cordelli
here in my house in tuftsboro not the
state house
[Music]
representative baum
uh
i can i count him as here if he's uh
he's listening
yeah represented
if you can hear him uh say he's here uh
he's we're not going to be voting so if
he
just knew representative knows he is he
is connected and he has the ability to
mute and unmute his
his phone line using star six
and if he needs to raise his hand it's
star nine
so he is muted right now but star 6
would unmute him
unmute ralph
ralph
representative rome
representative allard
i am here uh i am still in my house uh
locked in by ice and uh
i'm alone except for uh two golden
retrievers
representative lakis
i'm here in my home in hudson new
hampshire and
my husband may or may not be wandering
through
representative moffat
representative moffatt
[Music]
i know he's there
yeah there he is yes
yes
representative hobson
oh i'm here yes
representative andres
here home alone in salisbury
representative ford
loan in my office in chester
representative leon
holmen derry with the one-year-old
that's about to fall asleep that's why
he's fussing
representative sodie
families in that wander through
representative miller
home in new hampshire by myself in my
office thank you
representative luna erin hopkinson
representative shaw i'm here my husband
is in the other room representative
cornell
here is still in manchester alone
representative tanner
here in george's mills with my rescue
dog raven
representative mary heath
representative heath
she was only going to do the morning
the exact session
okay
representative mullen
here in the basement in bedford
representative lay
i am home alone in jaffrey new hampshire
representative woodcock
holmen conway new hampshire my wife is
here and my dog and we have a clean
fortune driveway
representative ladd
thank you very much representative ladd
is here in haverhill new hampshire
and
with the dog that had half my sandwich
thank you everyone
okay thanks everybody um welcome back
for this afternoon session uh today uh
in the afternoon we're hearing
hb608 this uh bill is a bill dealing
with the education funding formula
i will be
speaking regarding this uh
bill so i'm going to turn the gavel over
to representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman
um
so i will open the uh
hearing on house bill 608 related to
school funding
and uh i was looking for
representative steve smith the prime
sponsor
but we do not see him on the
on the call yet
so
representative ladd since you were
speaking on the bill anyway do you want
to introduce it and then speak to it
mr acting chair i think i see steven
smith in the education committee room
oh
okay
yeah there he is
all right we'll call on representative
smith in that case my goodness okay
thank you mr chairman there's the sound
down
yes yes awesome thank you i'm
representative steven smith sullivan
county district 11 akworth charlestown
goshen langdon webster and washington
house bill 608 has a long time coming
and addresses the
problem with stabilization grant
reductions
a little after i believe 2011 a new
education funding formula was passed to
address the donor town issue
and that meant that a lot of money that
had previously gone to towns would stop
going to towns it was so much money
that
nothing was done right then and then in
2013 a 14 a gradual phase down began now
when i say gradual
to get a handle on this there are 5 000
people in my town
and the gradual is a hundred thousand
dollars less in education funding over
25 years that's just
there's also uh claremont that will lose
a whole lot more newport loses some
franklin does manchester certainly
and we haven't done anything about
coming up with a new method to address
property poor towns and
towns that
don't have the property base
to deal with this uh the reduction i
mean five thousand people a hundred
grand a year that's a lot of money
well why don't why don't they just spend
less well we try to however
they are one town in a five town
district and my town consistently votes
down the budget but the fact is that
when we had that level of funding
commitments were made
staff were hired things were built and
those bills don't go away so even if
you've gone back to the default budget
it's just not a sustainable model for
these towns that have you know a
disadvantaged population
to continue to bear this now
some of the urgency
got taken away when we come up with
one-time money one-time money is not a
fix because well it's one-time money so
even if the effect wasn't felt quite as
hard in one year they have no security
and no way to plan for what may happen
the next year 608 is an attempt to to
address that and a
two-year study committee
delved into this they met with
stakeholders from across the spectrum
voters the superintendents association
the school districts themselves the
education commissioner and produced
report 2018 with a formula that would
address this now a quick note
why can't we just keep giving them the
stabilization grants because they're
based on 2011 student populations and
the legislature cannot send adequacy
funds for students who may or may not be
there anymore so i agree stabilization
grants have to go but the support must
stay
the roots of that report became house
bill 709 in a previous session which
made it out of this committee and then
died in finance
ultimately what we got was another
two-year study and still no solution and
still
the aid going down every single year so
my plea to you is stop the bleeding um
the
arguments about income tax capital gains
tax this source of funding that source
funding you know what i don't care
please pass the bill as is amend the
bill i don't care what you do as long as
it solves the problem of small towns
through no fault of their own at this
point through multiple administrations
of different select boards and school
board members finding themselves having
to deal with hundreds of thousands of
dollars in reduced aid every single year
um that's my pitch and i leave it in
your hands thank you mr chair
thank key representative do we have uh
questions for representative smith
uh representative lacas
yes i was curious um back last
biennium
when we went through funding
we took all of our step functions out
and replaced them with straight line
functions
and i was wondering um why you didn't do
that this time
because just one student can make a huge
difference in what a town gets
and i are just a small amount of
difference
so i'm
just wondering
the advice of education policy folks
smarter than myself i was asked to
change the initial version of a bill
that i filed and i concurred um eric
said it i don't really care what the
method is
some of the things that were brought up
with a look at free and reduced lunch
populations and assigned grants to that
adding in performance
i literally don't care on what the
method is and i imagine that your
committee will probably amend the bill
if it solves the problem of these grant
reductions to these towns
that's fine
any further questions for the
representative
i do not see any uh so thank you very
much representative smith thank you mr
chair and members of the committee
representative hopson um
we have uh jeff nick lynch scheduled to
testify next and i've promoted him to
panelists so go ahead please
um um mr chair point of order
yes
um so thanks very much mr chair i know
representative ladd i think had um had
sent an amendment over
yesterday to the committee
and
the amendment replaces the
every the amendment essentially replaces
the bill all after the enacting clause
and i was just wondering is this a um a
hearing on the
bill are we talking about the bill as
amended or are we talking about
the bill is not amended
right now the uh the bill itself um
the amendment has not been introduced
yet no i i understand but the bill
hasn't real i mean we're we're just
starting this hearing and i was just
wondering what what um what
representative ladd would would like to
do as far as what we're talking about
here
representative land
yeah i i uh mr chair
there is an amendment and the amendment
as representative states replaces the
bill
and the amendment has
been sent out to all people on the
committee
i think it's appropriate that
seeing that the original bill as it was
written
uh was a reflection of one of the
amendments that came up
what was it several years ago when we're
dealing with hb 709
and it
included uh components which
uh obviously uh
were not accepted uh so i think for
for sake of time here
i think represent luno is is correct in
saying that are we going to be
discussing
something that's not really on the board
at all as far as you know
logically i don't think we should be
talking about the bill as it was
introduced
unless you want to get into a great lot
of discussion regarding swep at this
time
and and or do you want to get involved
with the the bill as it probably will
look when it comes out of this committee
representative la uh chairman led uh i
don't have
that amendment
i did not see that amendment did you say
that it went out yesterday
yes it did it was mailed out
okay
same email that had the amendment to
what was it 613 i think
oh okay both amendments were on that
email right thank you
it's 0 0-3-2-3-h
okay i do see it here thank you
representative vlad would you like to uh
continue
your comments
well if you if you're going to recognize
me as a speaker
yes
i will do that
yes i am doing that okay thank you very
much uh
thank you very much uh committee members
for the record my name is rick ladd i am
a representative from the town of
haverhill
and i will address this bill
primarily from the focus of amendment
0323h which you all have
a couple just overarching type points
about this bill
as amend as it would be amended with
this amendment one
there it uh there is no change in terms
of incorp there is a change in terms of
incorporating swept in the bill swept is
not in this bill
so the changes to it
to excess swept monies
remains unchanged the town which is the
wealthy town now that can teach
keep excess dollar
keeps excess dollar
so that's as it is right now
stabilization
in this uh bill or this as it would be
amended stabilization is totally gone
that was a recommendation that came out
of the 2013 report
and i believe it was a recommendation
also from the funding commission this
summer and fall that
stabilization does nothing that's really
good
for education it's not reliable it
deducts each year that four percent
which is i i think even
deputy speaker smith talked about that
how it's it's it's tearing charlestown
apart it's tearing a lot of little towns
apart
the cpi
which we have that at the beginning of
every biennium
certain costs within the
adequate education formula are increased
according to the cpi that continues that
continues
does this uh amended version have
physical capacity disparity aid yes it
does and i will get into the components
the two areas within the bill that have
fiscal capacity disparity aid physical
capacity disparity aid was once in the
joint resolution that came out of 2008
the joint
legislative legislation for the costing
of an adequate education it came out
there it was taken out of
the
current formula
uh
of almost
now
a good eight years ago
going further
there
additional aid based on free and reduced
meal plan this aid is provided both to
the traditional school and the charter
schools
okay additional aid based upon equalized
valuation and testing scores as part of
fiscal capacity disparity aid that has
also been
added into this bill
so i will get into these these
components as i uh
go through the amendment
um i would also like to state one as one
thing right here which is a
constitutional issue when it comes to
funding
whatever the state identifies as
comprising a constitutional adequate
education the state must pay for
none of that financial obligation
can be shifted to local districts
regardless of their wealth or need
okay that comes out of the londonderry
case
so
and it's also the constitutional
responsibility
of the legislature
to
define adequate education
and those are two points which i've
tried to follow as i went through and
and developed this amending language
there are components to and the other
thing i would like to mention right from
the onset i know that there's going to
be questions that where is the fiscal
note
i i've contacted legislative budget
office
assistant and they have not gotten that
uh information together in fact they
haven't been even given this amendment
which has been out now since february 10
so i have contacted the department of
education and i've been assured there
will be a
fiscal analysis
as developed by them by tomorrow
afternoon
so moving on down here
one of the things that this bill
tries to avoid
is additional taxes
um
uh of any great magnitude and we i
understand that revenue and expenditures
are part of this whole thing
and they must be discussed but there
will be no tax dollar taken from a
wealthy town to pay the the needs for
education in a poorer town
that is not part of this equation
um for so increased costing for the
lower town will not be subsidized by
increasing or doubling the tax rate for
the community which has that higher
level of uh of ability to raise uh
dollars right now
so going on down through this bill as as
amended
there we still have a component called
base cost
base cost is the old cost which was
developed back in 3008
and at that time it was three thousand
four hundred and fifty six dollars and
that was the universal cost based upon
the high school and the lower end the
elementary middle school levels they
combined it and they had the one cost
now what i've got there in this bill as
the cost for the education in 2021 would
be 3786.66
that's cpi adjustments that's just
moving along where we are right now
so the base basically changes based upon
the cpi for the beginning of each
biennium
there also are components within this
where
adequacy is comprised of two categories
one of which is the base cost and the
other is your differentiated cost that
is the portion of dollars in funding
which supports the child who needs
additional support
to meet these
based needs
and
that those categories are the ones we're
all familiar with with the
free and reduced with the english
language warrant learner
and the special education costs i do not
have linked in this particular bill the
monies which if you don't qualify in the
other areas those three areas you would
get support for the third grade reading
that was not really a significant hunk
of money and i think it's better spent
if we allocate that dollar through
another approach within this bill
there is accountability within
this formula which develop is developed
for how we develop the adequacy
education aid
and the attic that accountability is on
page two of the amendment under 198 40-b
and you can read through that much of
that language is language which came
from the 2008 report
so we're using similar language for
accountability whereas the money that's
used for this has to be used towards an
activity or to
helping uh attain the
necessary
elements and needs that are associated
with adequacy
and as you know that we have we've
included those components for adequacy
and we did that the other day in hb 242.
those are the same components
that are within and put forth by the
commission back in 2008
how those components are changed in
terms of funding is a legislative
responsibility and i don't address that
here in this bill that's a legislative
responsibility to adjust those whether
you're going to be funding a classroom
based upon a 25 to 1 ratio or a 30 to 1
ratio or a 20 to 1 ratio or even lower
that is
that's a legislative responsibility and
both the report in 2018 that came out
and said we are good with the ratios and
the funding processes that for the
components within base adequacy that
define how we're going to achieve the
substituent criteria for an adequate
education
like to talk for a minute about the
fiscal capacity component aid compel
component because i think it's it's it's
agreeable that we all understand
that there is a
a real need to assist those communities
which represent representative smith
and others als all spring summer and
fall have testified before the
commission for funding that we help the
disparities that exist between our are
in our schools between certain groups
of students and between districts and
eliminate the inequities of one district
being able to afford the quality
education that we and all know
and the next district maybe not even to
be able to afford uh ap courses
and so we need to balance that out and
we can do that through this portion of
our funding formula
and it's based upon two criteria
the funding that came out of hb709
used primarily equalized property
valuation per pupil
this formula does that but it also
recognizes that there are communities
which have
high property values per pupil
but also have
low achievement scores or low medium
income other words the properties are
most likely owned or rented or leased by
somebody's not living in that town
however there's such a high demand you
see the property high and the difficult
like a lincoln new
hampshire and so what we've got is that
if the property value
is
approximately not approximately
1.139.999
below
other words dollars per
per pupil that's 1 million
139 dollars 999
000 999 dollars
then you would fall eligible within this
category down to a level of four hundred
thousand dollars
if you're at the lower end you're going
to receive twenty five dollars per per
student twenty five hundred dollars per
student on top of your base
adequacy and as you gradually get
towards that middle point as we had in
the bills all the bills we let dealt
with last year the funding for that
individual decreases
and to the point where you get up to
above one point i'll call it 1.14
million dollars per pupil there is no
extra of
capacity aid available
however this bill also like the 2018
report
only we changed it somewhat
where there was extra support given
based upon title 1 participation
however that information and that data
is not readily available from the
department as as as well as we might
find
the
level one level two level three level
four on the statewide assessment
back in 2018
when we were looking at this
situation of school funding i did a
report and presented it to that
committee showing achievement scores
of students which are in the lower
quartile and the highest quartile in
terms of equalized property valuation
and you can imagine and guess how it
worked the ones in the lower quartile
had lower achievement the ones in the
higher quartile had much higher
achievement but there were pockets
within both of those quartiles and
quartiles in between
where you had high numbers of low low l1
and l2 level 1 and level 2 performers
level 2 is you're not
a proficient and level one is you're
really not at proficient level three is
you're for proficient and level four is
you're way above proficiency
and so
the second part of this disparity aid
program provides support to any school
that ha above that 1.14
million dollars that has
for each of these students to the tune
of fifteen hundred dollars per pupil
so they will receive an additional for
every child that's not
at the level we want in terms of
performance or and growth
and there's a direct relationship
between low levels and poverty are free
and reduced
but there are those exceptions and we
want to make sure that all children are
being addressed in a in a fair and in
balanced manner so that they they
receive the opportunity for an
inadequate education
so that is basically the crux of where
we are
um one of the amended analysis in the
this report
indicates it says
it increases the base per pupil cost for
inadequate education by way of cpi
two increases differentiate
differentiated aid available to eligible
pupils
attac establishes fiscal capacity
disparity aid to municipalities based on
property valuation and
student proficiency
so there's two levels there
and number three requires school
districts to report on the use of
adequate education grant funds
and men's amends the law governing
transportation of pupils in kindergarten
through grade 12. we have always funded
transportation by the way in the base
adequacy formula
so that will con that continues
and it repeals of course anything to do
with stabilization so mr chairman that's
a quick summary
of this bill
uh the difference between this bill for
example and
where we were on the funding commission
which i was a member and of course i was
one that objected to the report and not
all the report there's many real
wonderful aspects of the report provided
in terms of the need to help youngsters
in our state all have the opportunity
for
that education we really recognize as as
what we call adequate
the bill we had 242 really defines
adequacy the elements that are part of
it
but this formula
costs those out it's an input-based
model rather than the model which came
out of the commission is a performance
outcome based model
based upon our total spending and that's
derived from the doe 25 form so we take
the average cost there of a child
and then we try to provide that level of
funding seeing that our state is on the
in the top five always in terms of
achievement in this country so we're
using that as a gauge
and
then the the amount that has to be
raised to get to that level
is distributed according to
where the the weighted needs are in
differentiated aid and base adequacy
this base adequacy and the bill you have
in front of you today
maintains it and only increases at the
cpi
where the other formula increases and
jumps it to approximately a little less
than six thousand dollars per student
but then in terms of differentiated aid
giving weights out
it weights a special education student
for example at 4.2 times the base
plus that base
and
that that to me leaves some room for
discussion that a kid that's in special
ed for only a half hour a week
is going to get funded that at that rate
if you change that weighted amount
you're going to have to increase the
weighted amount somewhere else you've
got to come up with this average
and it's not based upon the inputs it's
based upon that output based on doe 25
forms as submitted by the school
districts which include
all kinds of components
that are not part of adequacy
so in conclusion this does conclude my
report and and describes the amendment
in a a brief way
uh of where where this goes in terms of
the costing of an education funding
formula thank you very much mr chair
thank you representative
i see representative baum has his
handout
thank you mr speaker and thank you
representative left taking the question
uh since
2005 6 when i'm here we've been voting
on a lot of different
education funding
but one of the things we've always had
is a spreadsheet showing
how your town will make money or lose
money and i don't think this will pass
when we go to the full house unless we
have that spreadsheet because i know for
one i am not going to vote for any
education funding where my town loses a
lot of money or much money so i think
that's always been the issue
so will we have
a spreadsheet showing
comparison of town data
now and with this bill
yes
yes you will
okay thank you uh representative luno
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you very much representative ladd for
for presenting um 608
and i think there's uh there's there's
probably some very good good pieces in
it and i'll be looking forward to the um
to seeing the
the department's fiscal
note on this
tomorrow but um
and so much as you talked about some of
the the commission's work in
particularly
how the how the commission's
recommendations calculate the cost of an
adequate education based on based on
student performance
wasn't quite out it wasn't quite
accurate and um and i was wondering when
we might have an opportunity
um uh well of course there is an
opportunity coming up next monday
february 22nd at 2 p.m on zoom
it's a notice in the house and senate
calendars for a
for a
briefing of all representative
legislators
to the commission report but i guess
wondering when we may be able to to um
and
maybe it's after we get through this
early this plug of early bills
when we might be able to um to have a
zoom session with the house education
committee to really um you know dig down
into uh
what's what really goes into an outcome
or student performance
driven costing formula
thank you thank you very much
representative luno and i i
i know that you and i both
want the best for our kids in this state
and so i'm very open to a presentation
as i mentioned to represent mylar
a week ago or a couple weeks ago
that it i i would welcome that uh to
occur with our education committee um
and i mentioned then i'd like to have
that done after
the busy schedule we're in right now
and it'd be after thursday this week
then and i'd be glad then to coordinate
a time with you
um seeing you were the chair of that
particular commission and represent
milor the ranking uh democrat on our
committee right now um i think we need
to have an open discussion i think we
need to have a fair discussion
uh one of which um
is driving towards the same end to
have a fiscally responsible
outcome
that con that best serves these kids and
these towns where we have these
inequities in disparity i don't think
anybody dave is is questioning that we
don't have these disparities in these
inequities i think where we are right
now is at least where i am it's just how
do we
how do we raise that revenue and and
and how do we account for those needs uh
through our funding formula
great great well happy to work with you
on getting that set up
yep be pleased to do that great thank
you representative milor
uh thank you mr chairman and let me just
follow up with what
dave was saying
uh let me be real clear about
my issue on this and that is
i am i'm not a um
a um
a fact sheet guy i mean i i i have a
hard time looking at um
uh
information that's that's on a
spreadsheet
um some people like spreadsheets i i
in all candor i maybe it's because of my
age but i
dave lunos never met a spreadsheet he
hasn't loved all right
that's not me but what i was concerned
about when we got into this funding
thing
was how is this done
and what what you have before you and i
think what you're going to learn
is the two different ways
of funding schools
rick has basically proposed here a
continuation
of an input model
and an input model was created back when
it's been one we've been using and what
we mean by an input
it's more of an accounting model
in essence what does it cost
for an average teacher salary what's it
cost for an average principal what's a
cost
for internet i mean it's it's a thing
kind of costing
and that's what we had forever because
we never had
the ability to really look at student
performance
we have that ability now
with the various metrics
that we have
from kids who take exams etc
we now can target
where students are doing who are the
performance of students across the state
and what the commission found
was that in those low poverty areas
it was very clear
that students in those low poverty areas
were not
able
to receive the same kind of an
educational opportunity as those are the
more wealthy ones
and so the commission began to look
without getting into the specifics of it
but the commission began to look at a
different way
of funding schools
where you could take the performance of
students
and see where they were and provide
additional
dollars
into those school districts
to help them attain a higher level of
performance
that's the outcome based model
and those are the two models that that
are out there right now the traditional
input which rick is talking about
and the outcome base the on the outcome
base is not only student
test scores
but the level of which students perform
as they graduate and don't forget
graduation standards
are created at the local level
so if a student graduates it means that
they have in essence met that standard
so those are the two different ways that
we are looking at performing
funding of schools one is the
traditional input the other is tradition
is a new way of looking at taking
existing monies
we're not talking about new revenues but
and
making a fair allocation of that state
monies to locals that are really in need
and that's what you begin to hear about
that's what we'll talk about
at the briefing session next week and
then follow up with what rick was saying
earlier but i just wanted to point out
to the committee because when i first
got on this committee i didn't have a
clue
how this stuff was done
i have a little better understanding of
it now and i just wanted to kind of
share those two options with you now
can i
yes please uh please represent no i i
think uh representative miler is
uh
on the track that um
that i think we all can enjoy or
appreciate
um
one thing i want to really clarify
though that i believe input is extremely
important and i i think our identifying
specifics and in terms of unadequate
education
of those necessary key elements to
attain that those knowledge domains but
i also believe that we have another
component
performance outcomes which we measure
so i think you need both
and why i say that is that
um we we want students that graduate
from high school here to be able to
apply that knowledge and that's that's a
a a
an element which is kind of relatively
new in terms of our terminology and how
we address education we've always
measured it solely from achievement but
we have to also apply that
knowledge somehow
and
this is an issue that came out of the
funding commission and uh
not just the funding commission but out
of the advisory commission for queer
technical education
that
these
if you look at cte programs
three of the 14 key indicators of a
student being able to be ready to
graduate and receive that are based upon
cte type indicators
so when i look at the the group right
here number four which is in the top
quartile in terms of property valuations
i see 60 percent
of our kids are achieving on a
proficient or above level
but in those communities and these are
the wealthy communities
i'm seeing forty percent of the kids
still at level one and level two
this is why i've made an effort in this
particular bill to also provide support
and funding
to those level two one and twos
regardless of the quartile they may be
in
so i i look forward uh represent mylar
and represent luna to this discussion
um we have a long way to go as a state
in in funding our our education process
correctly and ensuring that the dollars
we are funding are used for those
particular tasks which we hope to
achieve with kids
thank you
representative moffett
uh yeah thank you mr chair uh
question is for representative vlad or
representative miler or anyone
uh is is anyone else concerned that the
the notion of targeting districts with
low test scores creates a little bit of
a perverse incentive to to not do well
uh
in other words if if you don't do well
you get more money is that a
concern to anyone else
well i think one of i think one of the
issues if i may rick
one of the issues uh mike that we need
to look at
is we can we can worry about just our
kids
in our community right
but yet on the other hand we then
shouldn't be talking about workforce
development across the state
because we should be worried about all
the kids in the state
and one of the things that the
commission was focusing on
the issue that you raised was how do we
begin to make sure that every child has
an equal educational opportunity
and if i'm in a district like dairy for
example
where
you know you there are problems down
there as it relates to funding as well
as claremont or newport or berlin or
whatever
how do we begin to create a fairer
funding system
so that those students in those
impoverished areas or the the
those that don't have the same kind of
equity in their property taxes how do we
help them
join that workforce
so that they have an equal opportunity
just as those students that are in
wealthy areas and i think
you don't want to you want we don't want
to stigmatize anybody but as we looked
at the data that came before us it was
very clear
that those students in those lower
poorest school districts they don't have
the same opportunities they've got
teacher turnover because they can't pay
kids they've got an administrative
turnover and when you don't have that
same kind of continuity that you have in
the more wealthier districts and so this
is a long-term issue i mean this is not
something that we're going to resolve
today or tomorrow but as we begin to
look beyond
where we have been we now have greater
data that we can really look at student
performance in a way that we never have
before and i think that's really what
we're trying to do is how do we provide
greater parity greater opportunity
for for an equal opportunity for school
for schooling
i'm not trying to answer your question
mike but that but but that's that was
the issue i mean and you'll see in some
of the graphs that we have that we
developed based upon uh the
form 25 from the doe after looking at
for 10 years you really begin to see
some drastic we do well generally across
the state but we have pockets within the
state that are in in great need
david i don't know you want to
did you want to uh
win yeah i i i
i think you covered it really really
well um no but uh i'll look forward to
the opportunity on monday to present to
all legislators and then later on
to the members on this on this committee
um and we can really really get down
into the the commission's findings
thank you hey please have one last
comment yes
um
it's not going to be just dollars which
fix what we have in this state
um
and i heard somebody earlier today say
education is a shared responsibility
between local and state and it is
and we all know the instruction
curriculum is a local issue
and we also know that there's different
aspirations
for towards education in many
communities we also know there's
different education levels
in communities of the general population
that general demographic
we also know that there's differences
from one school to another school in
terms of leadership and supervision in
that school
we know there's differences between a
great chemistry teacher and a teacher
that's in there just filling that hole
that's you know you can't find anybody
to teach chemistry
um there there there's all these issues
which are
are are relevant to this discussion so
it's not going to be just dollars that
fix it the dollars are imperative in
certain locations where we have these
inequities in these disparities
and we got to make sure that we're also
funding our education in terms of what
we define as adequacy
those are all key issues
and the legislature has responsibility
to delve into that and hopefully the
education committee will in in this year
and next year and really take a serious
look at that so there's a lot to this
but we do need a funding formula of
sorts because we're right there
in another another year developing a
budget for fy23
and and that's right now so something's
going to have to happen when all this
happens over in division two thank you
thank you
i see representative lakers has a
question
okay um
yes as as um
chairman ladd was saying it's very
complicated educating people
and
according to the um
community college studies
they have found that the more a person
the more education a person has
the more they make and one of the
differences even in communities that you
see a rich community and then kids who
don't do well
other lots of studies have shown that
how well a kid does in school is very
much dependent on the education level of
the parents
and um
i guess i'm not in some ways sure how
just
incentivizing schools to
i mean
the other thing is people work based on
incentives right
so
i'm not sure how throwing money around
solves the problem of the education of
the parents unless we're giving it to
charter school i mean not to um
community colleges to help parents get
higher levels of education
which that's
64 by
65 by 25 they're working on
and
incentivizing to me
okay so you give this extra money to
begin with like like we are in here
giving some extra money
to schools who are
not to students who are not doing as
well but i think we need to be
almost incentivizing for improvement so
you get extra money as a school
if you can show a certain percentage of
improvement because here we're
incentivizing as um
um
brett moffatt said incentivizing for
failure
and i think we need to incentivize for
improvement
is did you have a question for
representative lab
i'm sorry i was just joining in on the
general okay
okay
um we have rep mullen
and uh red blue now
okay representative mullen
thank you very much representative
cordelli um
representative ladd thank you for taking
the question on page two i actually have
specific questions on page two
line four
the words an opportunity for are added
prior to the phrase and adequate
education could you explain to me what
you hope to accomplish with the language
change in that section of the bill
well you know the we've always had you
know just plain
cost of an adequate education
but i think the word opportunity is more
in keeping with where we need to go in
terms of supporting and providing that
opportunity you know you're what how are
you going to measure just
adequate education is it going to be a
test or we can measure through the input
process
that they're providing the opportunity
they have
media specialists they have librarians
they have teachers they have textbooks
they have the supply money they have the
maintenance money they have the
transportation now is we are providing
the opportunity
for
an adequate education we're not
we and we are also providing the
adequate education yes but
i think it's important that our
phraseology which it does in many places
throughout this legislation when you
look at the cost of an opportunity for
an adequate education that's right there
in 198.48
they use the word opportunity uh i i
guess i guess what i was looking for was
whether or not there was a definition
anywhere of what an opportunity for an
adequate education actually consisted of
um
because i like you i've seen it in other
places but i can't find a definition of
it i was hoping that that's where your
language change came from
no it's going to come back from
discerning what you're how you're
defining education back in
193a and you're going to have to go back
to that level of statute to find this
because right here we're talking about
the costing of this
that back there it's the policy section
where we're really defining
what are the components what are the
elements what are what is that adequate
opportunity opportunity for an adequate
education
and it's that rigorous academic study
that we talked about a little earlier on
it's the
the all those components that lifts
those domains underneath it
um the substance criteria
for an adequate education that's what we
have to hike back and look at
all right i thank you for that if i
could just ask my second question
representative cordelia i would be
indebted to you
representative ladd in the bill analysis
it says
roman numeral 3
that
the law governing transportation of
pupils in kindergarten
through grade 12 is amended
and i for the life of me cannot find it
in this amendment can you just
point me in the direction of where the
language is that amends the
transportation language when i spoke
with mickey landrigan over an lba
after our exact sessions this morning i
said mickey that number three is i don't
know who put that in you
but he said a lot of times
there are bills that come out of
uh
legislative services
that have components in there which are
just not reflective
and where they find most of this stuff
is when they're dealing with hp too
and and that's where a lot of these
errors are found so no this does not do
anything the transportation is still
provided for our k-12 youngsters and
we're looking at costly and the costing
is the only place we cost that out is in
base adequacy okay good great thank you
i thought i i'm telling you i read this
amendment 16 different times trying to
find it so i couldn't find it
that's good that's very affirming for me
thank you
thank you representative woodcock
thank you very much to be able to go
back to the uh representative moffat and
lucas comet
if i may so i'm not asking a question if
it's permissible
okay
thank you thank you
representative uh
i'm get i get concerned when i hear
public education funding
based on incentivizing
uh
resources
it reminds me of the gentleman who
testified last week when he was talking
about mcdonald's and the french fries he
said take more money away and they'll
get better it reminds me of military
people who are involved in the military
who if we don't put money into r d how
do we expect our weapons to keep our
military forces to be successful it's
the same thing here if we don't put our
resources in those schools or systems
that need the additional help how do we
expect to have those youngsters get
better you take resources away from a
system that's already hurting and then
you just make it worse you clearly not
gonna be competitive at all um you know
it's like a team with five basketballs
or a team with one it's a lot less time
to practice when you have five
basketballs and one i guess that whole
that whole concept of taking money away
i'm not suggesting it shouldn't be
directed in a better manner i'm not
suggesting that but just taking it away
it makes me nervous thank you for the
privilege of representative codelli
thank you representative luna i believe
is next
thank you very much mr chair and um and
uh thanks again rick for taking the
question um uh representative smith who
who was the prime sponsor of the of the
bill
spoke a little bit about the urgency of
of the school funding issue
certainly as it relates to the the towns
that he represents and you mentioned it
yourself just a couple of minutes ago
that we're right there now working on
the fy 22 fy 23 budget
and that we need to do something here
and i was wondering if you could talk to
the effective date and how
how that
works with all this
well my goal on this represent luna is
that this uh and i agree urgency is
imperative
uh it would get to finance
and
the issues which are described here
i don't give a darn and nor does
representative smith whether this bill
is the bill that does it but we got to
inform
uh division two and those people are
putting together hb1 and hb2
to include somewhere in there
the
issues those principles those concepts
which we all are addressing
the the one issue i think where we
diverge is i'm concerned where the
revenue comes from
and and uh the
the amount of costing for some of those
particular areas uh within uh which i
spoke to earlier this afternoon
so uh
my concerns are i'd like to see this put
in effect for the beginning of the next
biennium
thank you
all right
yes okay
represent acting chair cordelli we have
uh
representative shaw would like to ask a
question yes here real brief like
uh i just want to go back to what
representative mullen said and you
mentioned uh representative vlad in rsa
from way back
what was that rsa
about the opportunity for
about the words opportunity for you said
it was back in the meaning of an irsa
uh that it wasn't in even
uh
yeah i was i was speaking to
uh where we have uh it was in 242 as
well it goes back to 193 e
3. oh okay
the usual one
yes yes okay all right thank you you're
welcome
are there any further questions for uh
representative ladd
uh seen
uh
representative hopson i think we have a
member of the public
yep uh
deagon
mckern i'm gonna uh allow you to talk go
ahead please
if you're there
thank you uh
chair and members of the committee um
it seems as though uh not being on the
committee myself uh was not uh privy to
the amendment
it seems that the
the donor town
issue has been resolved from this bill
for the moment
i would just like to
to add um on that it's it's difficult to
hear uh i guess repeatedly how much
um it's it's cut into uh wealthy towns
and and not wealthy towns and i don't
necessarily believe that that speaks to
the issue
at hand and i don't want to return
to the donor town language i do believe
that
you know it was seven when the new
hampshire community sued the state
arguing that education funding was
unconstitutional and 30 years later i do
agree
and that new hampshire is one community
i heard that stressed by a number of
committee members that we have to think
of children that don't live in our
district as they are our own children
and i strive to do that
but in portsmouth um
you know this idea that that everyone uh
is
is equally able to
afford that the house that the level
it's being assessed at
um it's it's just not uh it doesn't jive
with everything that i've seen
um as a city council member
um and you know
i didn't have to listen to my dad to to
believe that that portsmouth has changed
i've seen it you've likely seen it for
yourself if you just look at the tax
receipts
for the rooms and meals uh tax you would
believe that that there wasn't a single
home cook in in all of portsmouth but
it's equally foolish to believe that uh
that everyone in portsmouth can afford
to buy their house or even the taxes of
the assessed value of their house
today so i look forward to seeing what
comes out of
this committee
and the future of new hampshire very
much depends upon
that you guys come together and do a
great job so i thank you for your
service to new hampshire
thank you
do you have any questions
from the community
see none
uh
oh excuse me i do see one representative
lakers sorry
yes i was just wondering um what you
were saying has a lot to do with what
i've been thinking a lot about
um and wondering if it made more sense
from what you see in portsmouth and what
others in the state see it makes more
sense to base the extra money on
the ability to pay as opposed to
what um
a house is assessed at which may be
artificially large just because there's
high demand in that area not because
uh people are deaf are necessarily
wealthy and so if maybe some other
method that's based more on
[Music]
what people make
whether
that or
some way of measuring that people's
ability to pay as opposed to
property values what do you think
well i'm happy to take the question i'm
now a bit over my skis because i i i
don't know if i can speak for the city
of portsmouth uh in this but as dangling
mcagren's citizen
uh and council member uh i do believe
that we should take into account one's
ability to pay you know a house doesn't
pay property taxes people always pay
property taxes and i you know i was
listening to the senate testimony
on uh you know i'm forgetting the the
bill it was uh senate bill 158 uh and
often was referred to by the commission
uh i think it was charter 70 from
massachusetts uh that figured this out
and how to pay uh for an adequate
education but they do take in the
ability they do take the resident's
ability to pay they take into account uh
the wealth uh and the incomes of those
of those individuals in addition to the
housing values when they identify how
much those uh those different houses or
how much those different
communities are going to have to
contribute and until we do that i don't
believe that we're going to have a fair
funding model in in new hampshire uh
frankly but again that's me speaking as
an individual
uh answering a question
and not for a town of 23 000 people
thank you
you're welcome
thank you very much uh no further
questions i thank you very much for your
testimony and being here this afternoon
um and i think we have uh another
representative who just
raised your hand representative aaron
good afternoon everyone thank you so
much i don't want to take up too much
time i did send in testimony i have been
listening in i i didn't i'm sorry i
couldn't join you at the beginning
um
but you know one thing with this
particular bill is that i would really
like to see the stabilization grants go
away and and take that money that we're
spending on that
and put it into the adequacy money
that way because the adequacy money
really is is based on current um
enrollments and and i you know that's
where the kids are
so
you know i i just would like to see that
happen
and that's all i really have to say
thank you very much representative
um
questions from the committee that i see
so uh i thank you very much and enjoy
the rest of your afternoon
thanks
next we have paul de shane
welcome to education go ahead please
uh thank you my name is uh paul duchaine
and i'm a project manager with the town
of newington
i didn't anticipate speaking today but
the introduction of the amendment
uh changes the perspective newington has
on uh house bill 608
i had initially lodged an opposition
position to that and
you'll have a
subsequent written comment from the town
on knowington
in that vein
however i wanted to say with the
introduction to the amendment preserving
right to see and review and comment
later
it would appear that our objection has
now been overcome since most of our
objection is related to
again the use of excess swept being
a return to a donor town receiver town
model
that we feel is non-productive
for the entire state of new hampshire
for for various reasons that you'll see
in my written comments so
i i thank you
for this opportunity to address you and
now correct or or
amend my own
uh
opposition originally on behalf of the
town and uh i look forward to continue
to working with you all as uh we all
need to address this issue
thank you very much
um i do not see any questions so uh
thank you for uh your testimony today
okay it looks like last we have eric
froworth
go ahead please
uh good afternoon thank you
my name is eric frowarth i am the
administrator for the bureau of career
development for the department of
education
and as i reviewed the original bill and
again i also have not seen the amendment
but in the conversation it doesn't look
like the subject i'd like to address was
addressed
i would like to talk about uh the
inclusion
funds specifically for students in cte
into this adequacy bill
a quick
word search of rsa 193e which is the law
covering an adequate education
reveals some very telling uh
terminologies
the terminology computer science appears
twice
mathematics four times
science six
language 7
and career 10 times
while this may not be a direct
correlation to the intended significance
of the terms
the fact that the word career appears
more than any of the other quote unquote
core academic courses
is certainly an indication that the
drafters of 193
felt that preparing new hampshire
students for a career was a vital
component of an adequate education
as such i would ask this committee to
consider the inclusion of differential
aid for students participating in career
and tech education programs
as many of you are aware the current
tuition and transportation allocation
is directed solely at students attending
cte from non-host high school
our recent study shows that that
population represents only about 29 of
students in cte
what that means is as an average host
high school districts are covering the
cost of 71 percent of the cte
enrollments in their center with
absolutely no additional help from the
state
in some school districts such as
rochester
this number is as high as 98 percent
now just like special education and ell
cte education costs more
than a traditional classroom education
so as such again i would ask
that you would consider adding another
amendment including a differentiated aid
for students participating in cte
as was noted in the commission report
regarding adequate education and i'm
more than happy to uh discuss questions
or comments
thank you very much
um anything from the committee
uh yes
yeah
my unmute button just i can tap it it
doesn't like to on you
um
yeah my question was since it sounds
like you've done some research on this
can you make a an estimate of how much
more it
it costs a cte student than a regular
than a
non-cete student
sure we're all irregular so that's okay
um yes
it it does vary uh from school to school
as does the cost of any education from
school to school uh some of our programs
like business programs may only be a
small increase where auto or cosmetology
or some of the stem-based ones would be
higher
currently
uh the way the funding happens
it it is whatever is left in the pot of
money was divided among students and it
come
last year to about 3 800
uh was what the state uh put in for
those students and as we looked around
the country uh between 3 500 and 4 500
was about
um average around the country for what
um cte education costs above and beyond
um and to to just give you the dollar
figure of that if we used that figure
for all 10 000 of our cte students
that would be about a 37 million dollar
allocation into cte education
thank you
thank you very much
any further questions from the committee
i thank you very much for being here
this afternoon thank you
and uh
i know that there was a mr mcclinch who
signed up to testify i yep he's
okay go ahead please mr mc lynch
uh thank you very much can the members
of the committee hear me
yes yes wonderful uh well chairman ladd
representative milor members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to offer testimony this afternoon on
house bill 608 for the record my name is
jeff mcglinch and i'm the project
director of the new hampshire school
funding fairness project
as initially introduced house bill 608
contained a number of provisions that
would have strengthened new hampshire's
school funding system
for solve damaging declines in state
education aid in the coming year
and mitigated some of the inequities
that now plagued new hampshire's
property tax system
uh as i understand it the amendment to
the bill that's now before the committee
would preserve several of the key key
elements of that measure and address its
principle shortcoming
but it would also effectively strike too
much needed changes in the underlying
bill
and delay its implementation until
fiscal 2024.
the the new hampshire school funding
fairness project respectfully urges the
committee to restore those two sets of
provisions
and to return the bill's effective date
to later this year before approving it
in its executive session
just to expand upon those points
one of the more immediate gains found in
the original version of 608 was that it
created a new floor for state education
aid
to ensure that the amount of aid to
municipality receives in a given year
is no less than what i received in the
preceding year
and so doing that version of the bill
would have offered some measure of
protection
against the pandemic's possible impact
on school finances
i don't believe that language is now in
the committee's amendment and so we
would respectfully ask that the
committee reinstate some form of a floor
for state education aid for at least
fiscal 22 when it considers the bill in
executive session and you know just
the original version really recognize
the student counts we're seeing now and
i'm sure you're well aware of the
declines
that those counts are not likely to
reflect the situation schools will face
this fall fall
and set a floor under state education
aid to prevent those declines from
having a very real impact on school's
ability to provide every child
with a quality education
i should add that both the bill is
introduced and my understanding of the
amendment is that
it would build upon the progress
legislature made in the current budget
in bolstering state education aid for
communities most need
both in the form of additional
assistance
and fiscal capacity disparity aid
however we're concerned that the
amendment would not institute those
reforms until fiscal 24.
given the long-standing problems that
have plagued new hampshire's school
funding system as well as the new
challenges students families and schools
face
we would encourage the committee to
accelerate their implementation
into the upcoming fiscal 22-23 biennium
and i certainly appreciate that
this committee wants to work with its
counterparts in finance as the budget is
crafted but i think a very strong signal
from um this committee about the urgency
of that issue and the need to address it
would certainly help to inform their
deliberations
one other point i wanted to raise is
that
the original version of house bill 608
would have improved upon new hampshire's
existing approach to school funding in
another very critical way as it would
have ended the preferential treatment
that some property wealthy
municipalities
now enjoy under the statewide education
property tax and require every community
to pay the full amount of that tax
as this committee knows the new
hampshire supreme court ruled in
claremont 2
that to the extent and this is a quote
to the extent of the property taxes used
in the future to fund the provision of
an adequate education
the tax must be administered in a manner
that is equal in valuation and uniform
in rate throughout the state
in its current form the swept is far
from uniform cities and towns with
comparatively high property wealth are
permitted to retain any revenue from the
tax over and above what is needed to
meet the cost of inadequate education
consequently this the swept now
exacerbates the wide disparities in
school property tax rates that exist
throughout the state and the trail of
the opportunities available to students
in less well to do areas
restoring the swept is certainly
consistent with the findings of the
recent commission to study school
funding
and again while the original version of
the bill included those provisions um
this bill as representative vlad as
chairman ladd has described do not
include it we urge you to reinsert them
lastly there had been one problem with
the original bill in terms of the dollar
amounts used in the adequacy formula it
appears that the amendment now before
the committee remedies that problem and
we're happy to see that so in closing i
hope that we at the new hampshire school
funding fairness project will have the
chance to work with the members of the
committee and the sponsors of the bill
to address the concerns i've outlined
here and ultimately to build a school
funding system that fulfills the state's
responsibilities and that leads to
greater equity for students and
taxpayers like i thank you again for the
chance to provide this testimony and i'd
be happy to try to answer any questions
you may have
thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
see none so uh thank you very much for
uh
being here miss mcclinch thank you
and with that i will close the hearing
on hb 608 and uh hand the gavel back uh
to chairman lead
thank you very much i better unmute
myself here huh
thank you
um
there's an interesting conversation you
just had with uh members of the public
um and there are some things i think
that we need to be looking at
uh one of the things as the maker of
this amendment i i um
and somewhat concerned that it's not
starting at the beginning of the
biennium biennium fy 22.
um it should i think that's just another
you know catch within that particular
bill
um
so there are are a lot of issues and if
we have a second or two maybe we can
open up the discussion and and maybe
discuss some of that the last thing i'd
like to mention
is there's
there there was one topic that always
generated a lot of discussion with the
funding commission this previous year
and that was queer technical education
is that a categorical grant function or
is it a function that should be right
within
adequacy itself
um
that
i i don't think we ever got to ground
zero on that with a decision but we
recognize that there's much that has to
be discussed where is the perkins money
going how is that being sorted out
in regard to attracting more students to
the cte program how do we do that we
need to have some funding transportation
is an issue tuition an issue and that's
basically why we put together this this
bill and passed it unanimously on the
first day we had a session that was hb
304 there needs to be a healthy look at
that um sticking it into adequacy right
now i think would uh
you know um
i i i i don't have all the answers i
don't know where the perkins stuff and
how that's around nine million dollars
total and and uh
you we look at the tuition ranges in
this state from rochester where it's
thirty one hundred dollars per pupil
and we go to berlin which is seven
thousand three hundred dollars per pupil
with the average cost from five thousand
one hundred dollars those are the
figures that the commission was given
this summer
uh so um there are a lot of issues that
come into play here um
we need to take a healthy look at this
whole whole thing any other questions or
ideas that you know came up during this
previous hearing and i'd like to hear it
representing
where did i go
can you hear me did it work
yes
um
i just wanted to say
well i wanted to say a couple things i
really like figuring out how to
see what we can do about cte i think cte
is one of the more
one of the more important things that we
do in schools these days um
it's no longer limited to the few things
it was 28 years ago
and it does include a number of higher
tech
areas
i think it's very important
and
how we do that i'm not sure but i think
i agree that's something we really need
to be looking at and the other thing
just for
representative luno i wasn't talking
about taking any money away i was saying
started a base where we give money extra
money but then
the first year and then give rewards for
improvement it was to incentivize
improvement but start with here's here's
money which i think should be based not
on
valuation but should be based on whether
it's free and reduced lunch or median
income or whatever is going to most
capture
the ability of the residents of a town
to pay
give it based on that as a
here's a chunk to fix things now
fix things and will
somehow
reward you for improvement
that was at any rate that was just an
idea to bounce around
i don't even think i'd commented on it
uh mr chair
yes
um so so i think what you're talking
about here with cte is is really
important
and um but you know it's all part of the
it's all part of the problem we're
trying to solve you know getting getting
districts to be able to um to to fund to
to reach a funding
uh point or have the have the
availability of funds to fund their cte
programs it's the same problem districts
have about funding all their educational
programs and um and
and you know the
the the fact that that are our cost of
inadequate education the way it's set up
right now and the way it's been defined
for um you know for for for decades now
it's just so far off of the um the
actual cost whether it's cte or whether
it's other educational programs
and um
and i think you know more important than
anything else
is it and and whether it's cte or
whether it's anything else
um is uh is making sure that districts
number one that that that that that
estimated cost be the um you know
somewhat closer to accurate and or real
and number two that we that we use the
limited state dollars to be able to help
districts get there and um you know
right now we're basically you know
throwing a pile of cash to for every
every student it's the same you know on
average what is it 4 600 bucks here you
go good luck
and um and that doesn't do anything for
um uh for districts that need the extra
help
um so you know these are the things that
that and again it's absolutely true of
cte
um but it's it's it's true the entire
program
you know it's it's a hard one to crack
you know we're dealing with
you know all these constitutional
decisions
and
and and uh
trying to weave
a path through them
where you can quote one but then there's
another one saying that we can't slight
those even the property poor towns or
the property wealthy towns
does that we have to support adequacy to
them all
and and so to shift dollars you know
they're there you're trying to you know
walk through this minefield
and and i i think that's one of the
the issues and there's so many of them
you mentioned the categoricals at the
beginning there we have the same issue
with cat aid we have the same issue with
building aid
uh as we do with this area cte aid
and it's all funding oriented
uh we have the same issue with capital
projects for cte programs rotating them
every 28 years
on the 28th year your place is looking
like that garage in the street that's no
longer in business
uh so you know i we we have a huge issue
in terms of how we look at education
but
my suggestion is that we look at it we
have to prioritize and we're not going
to be able to do it all
brett miler had his hand up
and
yeah i think that's it miler i just want
to comment on a couple things that we've
been talking about
one one of the things we found is that
some of the uh communities
that have
poor property value are making a
tremendous effort
in trying to be competitive with
surrounding towns
and and yet in their effort they still
fall far short
one of the things we did find that in
the in this study over the summer
is that there was a question regarding
about well how do you value this
property
i mean what's the value of of a a
newport versus a hopkinton for example
and one of the things that the
department of revenue administration has
created and this is fairly new
that they now have a system it's called
the mosaic system
that basically provides much greater
equity as relates to how you evaluate
property so that's that's a real plus
the other thing that was mentioned
earlier and that is how do you deal with
people who just can't afford stuff
and the commission did look took a long
look at the issue
of of how do you get some property tax
relief
and what we found was that the current
program there is a current program
that it really hadn't been looked at for
over 20 years and the dra
basically said this needs to be revised
and so there is a bill of house bill 504
that's currently
before the legislature
that will address the issue of property
tax
that will move
the potential of somebody being able to
get a thousand dollars
rebate in their taxes to try to help
with deal with that issue
so the commission looked at both the
issue of not only what we're looking at
right here as far as the funding
but how is the funding generated what
are the options for it
and i think that was in representative
moffat talked about the issue of poor
towns
this is a problem it's not that the poor
towns aren't making an effort they're
making a heck of an effort
but they just can't raise the money
as much as you can a wealthy town
and the the thing that's important here
is that when you begin to look at
outcome-based assessment
you can
then if a property if a property poor
town begins to get additional money
you can actually then begin to say are
they improving
over a period of time it's not gonna
it's not a magic wand here but over a
period of three to five years if they
begin to get additional resources and
allocate those resources in a way those
students
should be able to improve and in fact in
the couple of the states that this is in
kansas et cetera where they have done
this the students have in fact improved
with that additional income and
additional support from the state thank
you
is there more is there anything else for
the uh discussion here it's a good
discussion
uh and it's of course you know we're
gonna get to have to get some resolution
here seeing that
we'll be creating hp1 and hb2 shortly
here
um
and and all this is going to contribute
to it
rick
yes yeah so so um just in the in the
big picture of things obviously you know
we just heard 608 that's
in this in this basket of bills
um so is um senator hennessey's bill
senate bill 135
senator conn's bill 145.
um
senator carncon's comprehensive bill
senate bill 158
house bill 623 i think was just retained
in um in the finance committee
this morning and that's an fy 22
23 hold harmless um bill
sort of what uh
what um
mr mc lynch was talking about you know
we've seen sort of an artificial
collapse in student enrollment during
the pandemic that would you know
drive the uh the adequacy
uh funding for the next school year and
so fixing that so these the the there's
there's there's a package of bills all
in here and um you know like i said i
like to say you know there's a pony in
here somewhere and um
and you know uh but these are things
that i hope members of this committee
are gonna gonna
take a look at following closely not all
of them are going to be coming through
this committee
yeah you know i recognize that i i knew
you had uh
the uh bill at the hold harmless at 623
over there that's what was in waste
means
uh finance fine excuse me finance yeah
um
yeah and i i i somewhere along the way i
i we're going to have to come up to
agreement on
some of those broad
broad elements that we've been in our
formulas in the past i for one can say
right now i'm not a fan of stabilization
and i never have been stabilization
becomes permanent
um
it's
something we've used we used it the 2008
formula had a hold harmless in it not to
the same degree i think it was only it
was underneath 30 million dollars
probably around 25 26 million dollars
and and and then
we have stabilization was created and
then you know back what 2012
um and then
slowly eliminated and people were
learning to live off of that
and and to compound it we have this
really decreasing demographic
uh which is and and we still have this
per capita formula you know somewhere a
long way i was just hoping maybe we can
get a formula be a built upon program
rather than per capita but i don't think
that's going to happen that's just a
monster of a task and
i can't see it so
dave we got a long way to go here and
somewhere in these bills i hope we do
find that that
point that's going to contribute to hb1
and hb2
who knows what it's going to look like
so
let's it's going to be the fight is
going to occur in division two
and then on the floor
um
i don't have anything else to say today
guys you know i've said this for for
months and months and months and i know
others right here have done the same
thing so it's uh
so is it time to call it quits for the
day
i see mel going up and down so i guess
it is
this um
this is representative uh just to let
you know my
checking with uh litchfield uh facebook
page other people have had internet
problems from 10 15 it seems to like one
so
and since one i've been okay so
so i'm sorry i missed that one vote this
morning right right when you're ready to
vote bam the internet goes so anyway
i've had that same quote i've had that
same problem ralph today too thank you
yeah so anyway
i mean i think a lot of it was
what the the school's being closed and
everybody on with school so anyway so
hopefully we'll see you all tomorrow
right okay so at this point in time
hearing on on
608 is done our work for today is done
uh i'm adjourning this meeting thank you
very much thank you thank you
have a good night everybody
hi all
so
you